hello everybody hello hello i'm sorry for being a little late i had to install something very very important um and i had to do something very very important very last minute because that's the joki way of course i would do the very important stuff 10 minutes before the stream starts um but this was incredibly important because i have some big news for everyone um So,
like, after my first stream, it was crazy because, like, Hollow Knight contacted me and was like, hey, do you want to try Silk Song early?
And I was like, oh, my God, I would love to try Silk Song early.
So I guess we're playing Silk Song.
now.
I can't believe it, guys.
Silk Song is real.
I can't believe it.
What?
Okay, buddy.
What do you mean?
I'm Jane Silk Song.
Is this not Silk Song, guys?
It's not my Silk Song.
She looks a lot shorter.
What do you mean?
It's her.
Is this not her?
I say this is literally Jane Silk Song from the one so real I can't do it so okay I need you to know I could have had a different skin on okay it took two people to tell me not to do it because I they're like no don't do that you know what we could have been instead of silk song this was my first choice
I had two people who were like don't do that but so anyway so what I learned was that you can apparently uh mod your mod your ignite to be anything you want there was I tweeted about it but until I don't know unless you guys make me a dokey a dokey night um a dokey night every part will be a different will be a different character it would have been based guys look I got silk song guys look at that whoa oh shit sorry silk sorry Jane um but basically every part will be a new character uh in my uh in my john holland night adventure until uh until maybe oh shit i keep and i'm not i'm not focusing at all until i don't know unless we get doki night then we'll just be doki night but for now i'm just gonna around with different custom skins uh you know what to do game mod dragon um so yeah guys look at that we're playing silk song guys a week early I mean,
it's basically it.
He's like, what else?
Okay, maybe she isn't.
Look, look, Jane Silk-Song just haven't hit her puberty yet.
Okay, this is the prequel.
All right, Silk-Song was actually a prequel of Hollow Knight.
So she hasn't hit her growth spurt yet, guys.
All right, don't, no bully.
No bully.
She hasn't hit puberty yet, guys.
No, no.
It's just, it's exactly.
You're just, We're just having a flashback moment.
Yes, it's a pre-sequel.
It's a pre-sequel.
Look at that.
Silk song.
I keep trying to kill her, but look at that.
You guys all got faded, sorry.
Also, other than that, other than that, we do have a big announcement.
We are launching our new merch apparel collaboration.
So if you're not following me on Twitter, I'll show you guys the video right now of the merch collaboration.
It's really cute.
It's been in the works for more than a year Basically like lots of back and forth with Gina.
It is what Gina draws.
I love her stuff.
I've known about her stuff Even before I was a youtuber.
So it was a great pleasure to work with her again She was it was originally supposed to be with the pajama collection But obviously all the stuff didn't get finished in time for the pajama Apparel collection for the pajama collection.
So we just like put it we just moved it until like like we have everything done in for to be released today so I'll show you guys the video it's so cute I love everything about it let me show you guys the video
so if you click on the link that's pinned in my chat right now you can pre-order all the entire collection right now the pre-order date will only be open for four weeks so get it before it's gone forever I don't know there's gonna be a re-release of it so make sure to grab them before it's gone forever a lot of also,
if you buy the bundles, it also comes with, uh, with like, uh, little extra, uh, goodies.
So there's, like, snapshots, uh, there's, like, snapshots, uh, an, uh, exclusive voice pack, um, that I recorded for it.
And also, like, a metallic pin for all pre-orders.
And, yeah, there's a lot of great things about it.
There's, like, the Dad set.
Uh, there's the Dad set.
There's the pajama set.
There's a comfy set.
Uh, I'm super looking forward to seeing everybody posting photos of it at the dokey for their dokey shrine um what i like about this collection is that it's not like full like you know like full-on like vtuber merch too so you can wear this wherever you go like the little dad hat too it's so cute the little floppy ears and everything so it's not like full-on like it's not like you know it's not very obvious that it's a um like a like a vtuber branded merch um and it's like very fashionable you can actually wear it and like accessorize and everything.
So I'm super excited.
I'm really excited to have all you guys receive it in the future.
But yeah, huge shout out to Gina Jaws for working with me on this collaboration.
Like I said, this merch collab has been in the works for more than a year.
More than a year.
Like we were in talks since like during the summer, basically, or even earlier.
I don't even remember Gina how long we've been talking about this collection.
I know.
Like, we were, we've been talking about this, we've been working on this collection for a very long time.
Like, I've already lost track on how long it's been in the works.
But yeah, anyway, back to Silk Song.
Sorry, back to Hollow Song, we go.
Real appreciate the stealthier merch.
I'm looking forward to buying it next to you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, here we go.
Back to Hollow Song.
Silk night.
Hello, here I go.
Where am I?
Let me check my map.
Even when I'm Jane Silk's song, I'm still lost.
Kevlar would be like, oh my god, I can't believe she got content for 100.
I baited so many people.
What's this?
The Dash Master.
What do I get for?
Oh, it's the little heirloom thing.
Oh, it's a secret.
Hello.
Get out of here.
Wow.
Oh.
God, I hate these little mushroom guys.
Wait, that's it?
That's all I get?
What?
It's just murder?
There's nothing else?
All I get, I killed these...
I killed these mushrooms and all I get was murder?
All right, time to look at my map.
Where am I?
Oh, is it was there?
I did a home invasion and they have nothing for me?
What's the point of murdering at their own homes if they don't give me anything?
Murder is its own reward, don't you?
All right, maybe is there anything else?
all right she's not playing as hordes she's playing as wasp watch what i think of the super chat thank you thank you where do we go there's like this bug here and i want to kill him is that's not supposed to go here i murdered these people yeah they wasted my time i oh my god okay give me a sec all right there we go i can't believe they wasted my time home invading their home.
Wait, there was nothing there.
There was actually nothing there.
Their secret was pointless.
Yeah, I guess.
I guess maybe.
Apparently I played really well as, like, my first time playing this game.
And I mean, like, of course I'm a gamer.
Of course I do.
What did you expect?
I am a gamer.
after y'all
but gotta consume the souls of these children that I've killed of the home invasion that I did okay oh wait oh yeah I keep forgetting you can parry this uh solid thank you for the super chat thank you thing it's time to get full set to get sick in pajamas it does not fit on my thighs no thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i hope the next second set fits this time i'd be i balance it up by being very very lost no i agree it's like you know like i'm just like well i was like where am i where where do i go no i will not ask for directions mary i can figure this out myself I am a man men don't ask directions we know I don't need help they should make better maps Cornelius takes these steps where am I oh he doesn't know how to fucking hit up nice I'm I'm a strong independent bug.
I'm Jane Silk Song.
That's right.
What happened to John Hollow Knight?
He's dead.
This is my game now.
We don't care about Hollow Knight no more.
It's Jane's turn.
We waited seven years for her.
This is her game now.
Alright.
No.
Oh, John all night.
My oh, she's.
He had us at time.
I played so well.
I unlocked Silk Song.
How do I open that door?
Can we stop to get Silk Song?
No, we have Silk Song at home.
And I changed Silk Song.
Oh, shit.
I wasn't looking.
I...
Alright, time to give me a second.
I gotta use the souls of the children that I've killed to get my HP back.
Alright.
I don't know where to go.
Okay, so...
Can't do anything here.
Oh, I can open this.
Is that open the other door?
Alright.
Oh, I'm so excited!
I released date!
I just continued Hollow Knight!
I...
I mean, like, oh, guys, guys, look, Suk San comes out.
Boots up all night.
Guys, look, I'm playing Suk San, guys.
Is this not what you wanted?
I could have, oh, yeah, there were, like, other, I was looking at all the mods and stuff that I could do, like, the skins and stuff.
And what did I get?
What is this?
The Mantis Claw.
Press A.
Oh, I can wall jump.
Nice.
I can wall jump now.
Yay!
Oh, that's cool.
I can Mario.
Nice.
Alright.
It's Mario time.
Oh, it's Mega Man time.
Whoops.
Okay, I'm...
You can tell I don't play platformers because I'm, like, trying to figure out how to...
Figure out the...
I'm trying my best!
I don't...
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
I'm figuring it out.
I've never played that, like, the Mega Man game or that Mario game.
game where you can wall jump so like i'm very confused okay okay okay okay okay give me a sec give me a sec i am jane silk song i can do this
it shows i told you i did not i did not grow up i did not grow up with platformers i did not grow up with that mario game or that mega man game the truth remains are vigil
Okay, MMV.
Is there anything over here?
Oh my god, please.
Alright.
Is there anything here?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, no, this is bad for me.
What even is over here?
What?
Was it just a shortcut?
It's just more money, right?
They'll open the door.
Why do we even get out of that?
Anyway, it's just money?
Platforming.
My worst enemy.
I'm so fucking bad at platforming.
It's literally just money.
That's really it.
No!
God damn!
Okay!
Oh, thank God.
Speed run.
Okay.
I mean, there's nowhere else to go, right?
Okay, I just have to go up.
Alright.
It's this way.
There's a speed run tech.
I wanted to die there.
Now where am I?
Okay, I guess I'll never know.
Yeah, that's good.
Okay, it's good because I actually need any of these guys to heal.
Okay, nice.
3 HP.
So I consume the souls real quick.
Now where do I go?
Where do I go here?
I guess here?
God damn it.
I don't understand.
Why can't I just draw my shit here?
Okay, I can't Mario this yet.
Those wall jumps give me Game journalist from competitor
Look at least I can jump I know how to press a guys.
It's not that bad I still pressed a
God damn it.
No, no, no, no, no Back down here No
I still pressed a Oh my god!
I hate this!
I hate wall jumping!
Okay.
Oh my god!
Get me out of here!
Okay, we're fine.
Oh wait, I don't need an alternate wall?
Oh, okay, now I know.
I should be allowed to, like, fucking draw my map while I'm walking around.
Where the fuck am I?
Really?
No, there's no reason to be down here.
Oh, it opened a hole in the village?
Oh, I didn't even know that.
Okay.
Yeah, they gave it a super chat.
Thank you.
I thought it was just a shortcut.
Wee.
I thought I just got a shortcut, guys.
Just looked like a shortcut.
Wait, how did they come back?
Oh, oh my god.
Is it that giant hole in the middle?
Is that... Yeah!
I'm this the biggest fucking hole in my life?
I wonder where that hole could be, guys.
Hmm.
Where could it be?
It could possibly be that giant hole, right?
No, that's way too obvious.
If it's a hidden village, they want to hide it, right?
All I'm saying is if it was a hidden village, they would have worked harder in hiding it.
Oh my god.
Okay, I can heal here.
This is my safe spot.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, there we go.
Nice.
See?
Yeah.
It would not be the most obvious hole.
Oh my god, it is easier.
If I just do it like that.
Okay, now that's the shortcut.
I told- What?
Knock, knock.
Knock, knock!
Let me home invade you!
I swear I won't kill all your family and friends.
I'll leave you alive so you can watch me do it This get locked down There's a maniac outside my door Let me in Jerry let me in Jane I want to see the kids You can't you can't You can't restrict me from seeing my kids, Jade!
Let me...
This is a free country!
Okay, that door is closed.
This door just gets deeper and deeper.
We can both be Jains.
This is what happened to John Hollow Knight.
That's why John Hollow... John Hollow Knight isn't allowed to show up anymore because um because jane got a restraining order on him they're my kids too exactly what
the do i go okay not like that all right i gotta farm him for like hp stuff
go here
ow I don't know.
I'm so confused.
Okay.
I don't even know where I came from.
Down?
I came from down.
I can't open this door.
Nor can I do this.
This door is locked too.
Oh, a place I tried to enter before.
What?
Where do I...
This one?
The shitty one?
This shitty area is where I have to go next?
Oh, no.
That's about my last life.
I gotta farm some citizens.
Some children.
Oh.
Oh, no.
I'm so fucked up.
Okay.
I'll go up here and then see if I can farm some stuff.
We gotta farm some children.
There you go.
That's one.
That's not a child, but I'll take it.
I'll take what I can get.
You know what?
I should buy some stuff, honestly.
Am I close to anything?
Oh, I am not close to anything.
Where the fuck is the Stag Beetle here?
Oh, this is bad.
I am not close to anything.
all right it's not a child i would know if it's a child because i'm used to absorbing the souls of these children oh
that was such a waste fine i'll just get just got it back anyway all right
oh my this like actually is like testing my parkour abilities of which i have none of which unfortunately i do not have the ability of Okay, there's that.
I am the child leader.
I know if somebody is not giving me children.
It's sustained me.
You can't scam me out of my children.
Wait, am I?
Oh, wait.
That's not...
I thought that was like...
I thought that was like a column that he couldn't get me.
Like, huh, what you gonna do now, sir?
Okay.
Yeah, unlock this, too.
Oh, this looks like a boss fight.
Oh, yeah.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'll come back soon.
I don't want to lose my mud.
I do not know where there's any...
I need to find a bench.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Guys, I have a thousand six hundred dollars.
I'm not losing my money
All right Bravely ran away.
Where is the bench?
Where is the closest bench?
I don't know.
They do not look very friendly.
They look Uh There's like a bunch of them and then there's a bunch of like Bug carcasses.
They do not look friendly whatsoever Okay Maybe better at the parkour stuff, though.
Where can I go?
I mean, the closest...
Bench is like, yeah.
Wait, Quora, what are you doing here?
You've been watching me struggle this entire time?
Hello again.
I suppose you're already met with the tribe of this village.
Hmm.
They seem a little distrustful of strangers.
dangers.
Put it.
They are not brids, though.
No, the sickness in the air that clouds the mind of lesser beasts.
They resist it.
They retain their intellect and their honor.
Though also their lethal traditions.
I have some words of advice, my friend.
You plan to challenge the lords of this tribe.
Your blunted nail may prove inadequate.
There is a city nearby.
The old capital of Holownest.
I've heard a nail smith recite, sir.
Seek the old bug out, and we find progress that much easier.
Okay, but where is that?
Can you mark that on my map, sir?
Like, oh, shit.
Wait, are you still there?
Sir, here's my map.
Can you mark that?
Can you mark that on my map?
Here, I have a quill.
Here, here, here's my map.
Put it, where, where is it?
Where, dude.
I'm just asking him to put a dot on where the fuck that is.
Where, He just says, go find it.
Please!
Where's my GPS?
Where is the closest direction?
Alright.
I'll sell him in trouble.
I'll mark it on your map.
Alright, we gotta go down.
I'm gonna go down so I can get to that bench.
Is there not, like, a closer...
Like, me...
At least I can, like, save.
save my map too.
Okay, there's the Mantis Village.
Should I go all the way back to the...
I mean, I could go back to the Queen Station.
I could go all the way back.
Yeah, it's not that far.
I'll just go all the way back.
Because I want to...
I want to spend my money.
I have money anyway.
Might as well spend it.
Take a shot every time Joki jumps into the acid wild yapping.
I mean, it doesn't hurt.
okay all right we'll just go back no I want to grab my upgrades oh I have upgrades for a reason okay we go this way and then I just go up I mean I have wall ride now so it should be easier too
it should technically be easier hey guys so All right, we'll go this way.
Yeah, it's a lot easier with this.
Okay.
Get over here.
Why did you fly up?
All right, and then we go this way.
All right, let's just ignore them.
We'll just speedrun it.
Boop.
You don't matter.
Okay.
Okay, and then we go up.
And then we go...
Oh, shit.
I forgot about these stupid fucking mind shit.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Okay, and then we go left and then up.
See, we're making progress.
I mean, we're making negative progress, but progress is progress, guys.
It's still considered progress.
It may be negative, but it is progress.
Progress.
Reverse progress.
Okay.
And this is this way.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Oh shit, I wasn't supposed to go up.
Alright, go back down.
It was actually this way.
Oh wait, did I open this?
I did, okay.
Alright.
And then we go.
Okay.
up somehow this way backtracking we're playing we're metrovanian
guys we're doing it we're metrovanian wait why is there paper here oh my god i i forgot that's where cornelius is this stupid map monopoly all right Alright, now we should be able to...
Now we should be able to afford...
Uh...
Afford some upgrades.
Oh my god, it's you, not you.
Here we go.
Hello.
Whoops.
I would like to go to Dirtmouth, please.
I have a lot of money to spend.
With money, you can exchange for goods and services.
Oh, wait, that's not what I want.
Stop being me.
Never!
You should stop trying overcharging his stupid fucking maps.
Alright, nice.
Alright, what do I buy?
Simple ill-fit, which is usually like to poke around places you don't belong.
Life in...
Okay, we need...
Oh my god, we're 200 short from the lamp.
Oh.
um he could give it to me for free he doesn't need a charge if he's such a nice person why don't i get maps for free i am super close to uh it's it's worth getting lantern okay so i need 200 all right where can i farm to oh hey he's here you there man why are you choking up on the shadows Yes,
your eyes do not deceive you.
I am Zolta Mighty, a knight of great renown, man.
Tremble before me.
While you're hiding there in your dingy little village, I venture into the dark pit below us and slew a great beast.
It had sharp mandibles and atrocious manners.
Yes, yes, all glory to me, but I don't have time for adulations.
I must rest and prepare for my next journey down.
Get out of my head.
Wait, who's he?
Santa.
he so pal thing you wear that nail with ease if you're in search of combat you'll find no great warriors in this decaying burrow i've heard an arena exists somewhere below why don't you build for the like meet me there and we'll test what skills you possess i'll be heading down soon come and find me if you dare oh he looks like a tumblr sexy bug he's wearing a mask guys what is be hiding behind the mess.
Alright.
We gotta figure out.
What can I...
What can I farm?
I need to figure out where I can farm.
Oh, is this the arena?
I feel like I'm gonna die.
This feels very arena-like.
Oh, no.
It's the temple of the black egg.
Do not blink the bug.
Remember that?
Miku bug thing?
that was like so popular like 10 plus years ago that was so freaking freaky there's like a song based off of it that miku yeah there was a really yeah there was a really popular miku song that was based off of like the bug the bug miku
oh shit you're right i have so oh my god forgot all the all the children my paychecks my ransom I gotta claim my ransom.
No, no.
It's where Miku had...
Miku...
Hatsune...
Miku Hatsune.
I was like, that sounds so rough.
It's where Hatsune Miku had like...
It's like a full fucking freaking nurse bug.
Does no one remember it?
I gotta claim my paycheck.
What are those paychecks called?
Where like, if you take care of a...
If you take care of a...
like a of children who are oh my gosh or in protective custody or they call it again child support no not child support yeah when you take care of children in foster care and then you get like special paychecks for it how much should I get paid oh oh oh Is it war alimony?
War to this day?
Oh, hey.
And this.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's a piece of the mask.
It's really fucked up.
Have you guys ever read about it?
Where, like, there's some parents that take a bunch of...
Is this stipend?
There are some parents that take a bunch of children from foster care just to get paid by the government, but they, like, treat the kids really poorly.
It's so fucked up.
That's basically what I'm doing with the bugs.
I'm doing with the caterpillars.
I'm here to collect my government check.
I did it.
Toki.
Yeah, it's pretty fucked up, right?
Anyway, I gotta collect my government check.
I... Oh my God.
It's bleeding.
That sucks out early access.
Free the crumbs.
I did not say that's what you wouldn't say.
Oh, shit.
Okay, there's a big bug over here that I can find.
You have...
Oh, it's a hot...
No, I don't care if I have enough.
I gotta kill this guy just for the sake of it.
No, I'm just killing him.
Oh.
All right.
I have enough.
I'm killing you just for fun.
There we go.
For the love of the game.
I didn't even need to kill you.
That one was just for fun.
Guys, if I find more grubs, I get paid more by the government.
They don't need to go to school.
They'll just, we need, they just need to take care of, they need to go find jobs and take care of each other.
I am a good parent.
I am foster carrying them.
Alright, I can buy the lamb.
Ascend.
Alright.
Lamb time.
Yay!
Where's the mini confession sad?
Sad when you need it.
Or thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
What?
How?
Is it?
automatically equipped?
Can't tell.
Do I have it automatically equipped?
Because it's like a...
Oh, okay.
It is.
Alright.
Go down, I'll go.
Okay, now I can go to Queen Station.
Don't worry.
As long as I confess my sins, I shall be forgiven.
Alright, just in case.
If I die heading there.
Up I go.
Oh shit.
It's supposed to be this way.
God damn it.
Okay.
I missed the wall there.
Alright.
Next boss is the real skill.
Check don't worry.
I was born to game.
I think this way.
This is the faster way.
Is it?
all right let me double check my map okay here and then we go this way
no down here okay yeah it's down here is it down here yeah it is
then we go this way and then we get the shortcut
yay Born in the 360 nose, go.
Alright, and then...
Oh, wait, I can just go from this side.
I could get the bench, though, just in case I die.
Yeah, I'm just gonna... I'm gonna grab the bench just in case.
I feel like that's gonna happen to me.
Honestly.
Yeah, I mean, like, I'm already getting shit on by this stupid fucking mantis.
Wow, yeah, God sucks on really.
It's crazy.
Okay.
Well, I now figure out the pattern for this.
Go down from here?
Oh, it's this way.
Alright, and then we go down.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I keep forgetting you can parry.
I keep forgetting that's a feature here.
But I feel like I'm still gonna fuck it up anyway.
Because the timing for parry is...
Seems like really tight.
If you don't know, like, the...
If you personally don't know the timing of it.
And I definitely don't know the timing.
Yay, Pogo!
Alright.
Well, you got this bench.
Alright, time for the Mantis.
How do I get there?
Give me a sec.
I'll check my GPS.
Syria, where is the Mantis?
Okay.
All right.
I gotta absorb the souls real quick.
God damn it.
These are so annoying.
Oh my gosh.
Why didn't that POGO?
I do need a farm in these, though.
Parry?
Okay, parry.
Oh, shit.
Fucked with me, I guess.
Where is...
Oh, it's one...
One area higher.
Alright.
Wait, actually, I need that.
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
I accidentally used the magic.
I wanted to, like, upgrade my souls to max before I go.
God damn!
Okay.
Stupid acid trip.
Alright.
All right, now I go down the hole.
Oh, God, I was so close.
I was like, it's fine.
And I forgot.
And I wanted to farm this a little.
This way, and then we go down.
All right, we go this way.
go to this yeah guys this does not look safe there's really two skulls on the stick there there's multiple skulls on the stick guys oh look does that say challenge oh yeah okay i'm yeah i'm dead there's three of you oh my god okay no i'm fucked i am so fucked no i i am absolutely not winning
guys i'm not first trying this
okay all right now i know i hate that was so fast did anyone get the license plate of that mantis did anyone did anyone get the license plate of that mantis guys holy fuck i don't even know what happened happened so fast.
What the fuck happened to me?
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
And run.
Alright, we gotta go this way.
The mantis lord.
I was not ready for that.
Holy shit.
That's the new filter.
That was is definitely the new filter.
Not the fucking Jane Silk sign.
There has to...
Is there no closer bench?
Like, do I have to do that?
Oh, hey.
Nice.
Wait, where the fuck did he come from?
I feel like there should be a closer bench.
you beat them oh my god stupid monopoly on benches there you go all right i think that the hardest part is just the fact that it's so far i hate how far it is all right can i maybe not challenge you
These, sir, I just need one bench.
It's not fair.
Why can't I have the bench?
Okay.
Just wanted to...
Okay, that's...
Alright.
Okay, there's that.
Okay, there's that again.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, this is wait.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, that was just me being greedy.
Let's see.
I'm making literally...
Alright, yeah.
Okay, I understand.
I understand now.
Alright.
I understand.
his pattern is like pretty easy yeah unless he has like a second fucking phase then like then i don't understand you know if he gets into another phase then i i stop understanding but for now i me understand
actually i'll try to when he does that fuck okay never mind fuck He doesn't let me charge you up for that.
Oh shit, there's two!
Oh fuck!
I'm glad you know we'd be cool!
Guys, we're not cool, apparently.
We're not cool.
Jesus Christ, okay, that's bullshit.
I don't even know when I can heal, honestly.
Like, what?
Oh, can I bounce off that?
Oh, I can!
Okay.
I get it.
I can bounce off of it.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, that's a lot.
Okay, I ran into him.
Okay, I understand that.
Okay, this is easy.
I was like, wait, I can't avoid this.
All right.
I figured it out.
I downloaded the pattern.
I've downloaded you Okay, that's good that I can I thought I couldn't bounce on it That's what I was like What the fuck
I just don't know when I can heal It feels The acid got me again
I think the hardest part was just literally Figuring out when I I can heal, because I don't know yet.
When there's two of them, I feel like I can't heal.
I'm not sure.
Timmy seems, like, incredibly tight.
I guess if I had the... I think if I had the...
What was it?
That charm where I can heal with the armor, I have to use the armor charm or some shit.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's...
was on me that is also not me all right i just wanted to had more power up but that was a waste actually there you go that should be enough no thank you for the super chat thank you thank you crazy style all right i understand get down from here
Yeah Nice Yeah, all right The magic is so strong which I like
Gotcha just in time.
Oh shit.
Okay, not oh Okay my bad My god a little too cocky there.
Whoopsie, dude.
Maybe?
No.
Can't heal that.
Oh my god, I can't heal that either.
I'm trying to figure out when I can heal.
I'm going to stall this a little bit so I can, like, heal.
That won't be full HP.
Oh my god, you fucking whore!
He won't let me heal!
You're so mean!
He's so mean!
Just wanna heal!
Why are you like this?
Okay.
I'm just such a bitch!
Okay, fuck you!
I won't heal!
Fuck you then!
I don't need a heal.
No heals for you.
He's so mean.
Such a mean person.
That's why nobody like- No, that's why nobody came to your birthday party.
Fuck you.
This is the only time- Okay, this is actually the only time I can heal.
That's fucked.
oh shit that's so that is so fucked okay oh my god okay i get it i messed up i messed up i messed up i will admit i messed up there i my anger took the whole of me all right no i get it i'll just heal during like the intermission sorry i got angry
That should have been, like, that should have been it, but I got angry.
I let my anger get the best of me.
Oh, I could have swapped my charms.
It's alright.
We're committing.
It's okay.
We're committing it to it.
Alright.
That's why nobody came to that guy's birthday party.
Everybody hated him.
Good.
It's fine.
He's actually pretty easy.
Um, but like, I got really cocky and then angry.
Alright.
I'm ready for real.
Like his patterns are pretty simple.
But anger spoke to me today.
Okay.
Alright.
I hit him, I think.
Yay!
Oh, I want to poof him.
Whoa!
Hippie!
Alright, hit.
Whoa!
That's right!
Can't catch me!
So I'm the gingerbread man!
Nice.
Use the magic tier.
Wait, did I hit him?
I can't tell.
I actually can't tell if I hit him there.
Oh, shit!
What?
Oh, you bitch!
I got
comboed me!
He's not playing fair!
Ref!
I demand the referee.
Sorry.
He ain't fairly fair, sir!
There we go.
I can only use it once though which sucks this one is like scary ah the two oh my gosh when it's two it's like a lot scary because they combo like what I have to stay in the center yeah I have to stay in the center then he's gonna do that oh my Okay, that was down.
Ref, I caught a foul.
Oh, yeah, all right.
Let's get rid of this.
We don't need this.
Oh, I don't think we need swarm if we're going to be here.
I think I need this so I can heal.
Wait, oh, I can't do that.
Maybe those will move around us.
Oh, wait, I can dash up and down.
Would that be good?
I feel like that would be good actually I'll do that
Wait what Okay Is that But I thought I said I can dash up
Oh I can dash more And that does it actually No you don't understand I need the compass You don't...
You don't...
You don't understand.
I need that compass.
Used by Shaman Draw More Souls from...
I feel like I do need that, actually.
Okay, fine.
I'll take that so I can get the...
I'll take that, because we need that.
Do I need Dash Master?
I don't know.
I feel like I don't really need the Dash.
But we'll try.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh, fucking horror.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, no.
Okay, the dash save me.
Oh my god.
Yes, we need the dash.
Never mind.
Dash is good.
That dash actually saved my ass.
Alright.
Nice.
If I didn't have that dash, I could have died.
I almost died there.
I actually could have died there.
I saw a life dash before me.
Okay.
That's a...
Oh, shit.
God damn it.
Accidentally fucked up.
And used the magic.
Alright.
Nice.
I sort of...
I need the...
Actually, no, I don't need full of magic.
Or full of solos.
It's when it's 2 that it gets so complicated.
Oh, fuck!
I didn't mean to dash.
Oh my god, that was actually...
That was an accident.
Ah, no!
This is my bad!
Bad run!
Okay.
Are you serious?
Okay, yeah, this is a bad run.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Ooh.
all right nice nice i hit him get over here whoa that's right oh my god no i forgot to run it's not fair there
was nothing i could do
This is actually so fucked up.
This is so fucked up.
No, shit!
I just don't get hit.
I don't know if I like...
I feel like I...
I feel like I don't dash as much.
I'm going to take the dash off and just get the heals.
Yeah, I don't think I...
dash that much in general to acquire it.
So I'm going to use the I'm going to use the focus.
The focus so I can heal during the phases.
Yeah.
Alright, six times the charm.
No, I fucked up during first phase because I wasn't paying I wasn't paying attention.
I wasn't locked in.
Alright.
I understand the pattern.
I just wasn't locked in there.
Yes.
Alright, we got full.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
I wish they have an HP bar so I know when to heal sometimes.
So I don't accidentally.
That's right.
God damn it!
Fuck!
I was distracted.
I actually...
I actually trolled there.
Oh, it's just TK trolling.
Are you serious?
What?
Okay.
What is your fucking hitbox, little man?
Sorry, big man.
Hitbox is dumb.
Are you...
Okay, I'm missing my magic.
Ooh, now.
Alright, sorry.
Doki, don't be angry.
Stop being angry.
Your anger is fucking you over right now.
Be calm.
Meditate.
Okay.
I'm just rushing it too much, I think.
I think I'm just rushing it.
Okay.
I'm trying to charge it up so I can...
Alright.
Inner peace.
Just gotta find inner peace.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
All that I need is inner peace.
Alright.
Oh my god, that's so bullshit.
Okay, I'm locked in.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
I got greedy with the magic.
I got so greedy with the magic.
Alright.
Nice.
Go, dokey do.
Inner peace.
Don't let them win.
If you get rage-fated, they win.
Just don't get rage-fated.
That's what they want.
Don't let the monkeys win.
Don't let the Superman monkeys win.
Oh my god, I've missed that.
I don't know how.
EH!
Hey!
Don't let them rage me.
Okay, one down.
Nice.
Heal, just in case.
This is the run.
Nice.
Yay!
Okay, not gonna lie, they're actually very easy, but I kept getting rage baited.
Because their patterns are so easy.
I just fumble because I angry.
I angry.
I got angry and greedy.
I don't think they're that hard, not gonna lie.
Bro fell for the rage bait.
Has to be a bench nearby, right?
There's a secret here?
Who's that?
This gives me the cringe.
Wishes little teachers.
We're still all over the place in the past, isn't it?
Shire a dark, twisting maze.
Unless you're well prepared, I urge you to leave.
Go to give you the song, you know.
Would you like to buy my map?
Oh, now it's $38.
I guess the map bubble finally burst.
Thank fucking God.
Thank God the map bubble economy has burst, guys.
I'm so happy.
He doesn't deserve my money.
Yeah.
Uh...
Do I have to go?
What is this?
Oh, it's just money.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I didn't know where to go.
You're so mean.
He doesn't deserve my money.
I thought you guys said there was a bench here.
Bench where?
Guys, you said there was a bench here.
It's back in the village?!
Oh my god, I'm leaving this village.
Alright, I'm going back, I'm leaving.
I'm going back to the village.
No benches.
Oh, there you go.
What is, how do I get that mask?
Alright, this way.
Hello guys.
Hey.
Oh, do they respect me now?
They're bowing to me!
That's right.
I'm James Silkson.
They respect my authority.
Oh my god, look, they're bowing to me!
Can I kill one of them?
Oh.
I'll acquire your soul.
I okay I thought they would be like I don't know I thought they let me kill them bow before your queen I'm hungry feed your queen if I kill enough of them will they still be friendly to me you're so evil I require a sustenance who let's themselves be killed.
I'm called followers for one.
Daka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fun fact, Converse White makes him charge for his maps.
He'll happily give it to you for free otherwise.
So stop being mean.
Oh, so, oh wait, there's the bend.
Oh, so the wife is the gold digger.
Okay.
That makes okay, now I understand how he's with her.
I don't think...
I don't need the shell anymore, so I'm gonna grab this.
Such slander.
Nice, what's that?
Mark of the Pride.
What's that?
Oh, wait, wait, that's good.
How much is it?
How much does it require?
Three!
I don't have enough.
I have to get rid of these.
I don't need the souls, though.
Okay, when I have more fucking slots, I'll use it.
I don't have more slots.
Alright, nice.
What's this?
Hollow Nest Seal.
What?
Where is that?
Where the fuck is that?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I can buy more slots?
How do I buy slots?
Oh, money!
That's right.
I'm your king now.
Your treasury is mine.
Oh, I can sell it?
Oh, nice.
Alright, we'll sell it later.
Alright, where do we go now?
Uh, alright, so I killed it.
Did...
So I guess I completed this area?
We go to the deep nest, right?
Alright, let's check the map.
Alright, there's the green path.
Do we do the deep nest next?
Where do we... What's the next area?
I have to explore.
Go Queen Station?
I can go to the city?
Where's the city?
The big statue?
Is that the city of tears?
Wow.
Where is the city of tears?
Where the fuck is that?
Is it to the right?
I'm just like I like my little guys just like where the fuck is city of where the fuck is city of tears put in fungo ways okay oh from here okay all
right so it's like oh it's up here okay city to go all right it's this way
Alright.
Go this way.
And then to the left.
That's right, respect me.
I killed your fucking kings and queens, I guess.
That's right.
It was me, a dokeybird.
It was me, Barry!
Okay, this way.
Okay, why don't the exploding mushrooms respect me?
They are alive, but they hold no respect now.
Ow, fuck.
Are they truly alive and nobody respects them anymore?
They might as well be dead.
Alright, this way.
Okay, okay, it's to the right.
So it's this way.
Oh, I can do this now.
now.
Okay.
Now that I have the moth... What the fuck?
Oh!
Alright, anyway, as I was saying, now that I have... God damn it, not again.
Okay.
Now that I have the moth thing, I can do this now, guys.
Alright.
Honestly, thank you for the raise.
Thank you.
Because I can do this now that I have...
Yay, speedrun!
Yeah,
intentional!
It's just a speedrun tech, guys.
Oh my god, I hate parkour so much.
If I could just do only the boss battle and I give my controller to someone else to do all the parkour parts.
I did it on purpose, guys.
A large knight statue.
socket on his chest insert the city crest sure into the when there's a hole there's a goal
oh he's sleeping
hello knock now oh shit okay not friendly not guys i think they were not friendly
Alright, nice.
I'll just...
Oh hey, there's a little knight there.
Go up?
Oh my god, I don't have a map for this area.
I gotta wait for fucking Cornelius to sell me this goddamn map again.
Is he blind?
Oh shit, no, he's not blind.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, alright.
At least he gave me some souls to divide.
Where is the exploding man?
There he is.
All right.
I have one fear.
And it's those who don't fear for their own lives.
Because if I have zero natural survival instincts, I fear someone who has negative survival instincts.
Exploding is just it.
It's just a way of saying hello.
Hello.
It's just a way of getting close to me because it's more intimate when they're...
When their intestines are out in me, right?
It's so much more intimate when their insides are out all over me.
That's when you know they're real friends.
Get a friend that'll just explode on you.
That's a real one.
Because they can only do it once.
Wait, can I...
Oh, I thought I could go out.
Go down.
Go down?
Oh.
What the fuck was that then?
Wait, what was the other thing?
The great gates have been sealed.
None shall enter.
None shall leave.
Oh, these guys are like those cities that close off and stuff and doesn't want it.
It's like Wakanda!
It's Wakanda!
They don't want to interact with nobody.
It's Wakanda.
I'm bored here, Richard.
Yeah, none shall enter.
Hello there.
I want to talk?
The capital lies below us, my friend.
What a somber priest, it seems.
And one that holds the answer to many a mystery i too have felt the pull of this place though now i sit before it i find myself hesitant to descend is it fear i wonder or something else that holds me back how did he get into bakonda bakonda forever
and now thank you for the super chat thank you thank you what can we say don't We see it here when we just need to explode.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I did not expect him to hit back.
Can't believe he would hit back like that.
Oh.
Nice.
It's over there.
Open up.
Give me your money.
Oh, he was guiding his life savings.
That's why your kid's not going to college today.
Okay.
What's this?
Oh my god, they can fly?
Oh shit.
Alright, nice.
I don't know why I'm here though.
Ow.
That is so rude, sir.
Yeah, they fly now?
I know I'm going...
Okay, it's in Metrovania, so there's no such thing as, like, a right and wrong way.
Oh, it's just parkour.
Goink, mine now.
Okay.
Hello, come back.
Come back.
I need your soul and your money.
I need your college fund.
Because I have an addiction to maps.
Okay, obviously, like, this is the right path.
So, that's right.
I'm a pillager.
Downstairs.
Oh, it's a stag.
Sack Station is here.
Right?
Wait, what does this map say?
What is this?
I can't read, but conda.
Oh, it wasn't a station.
What the fuck is that?
What's over here?
Wait, what did I open?
I have to go down.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me kill him first.
to make sure he's... I gotta make sure his bloodline is gone before I go anywhere.
It's the most important part of any video game.
All right, I want to check what this is.
Wait, I'm still going up?
Holy shit.
Oh wait, I hear a child!
I hear my stipend!
It's like somewhere here!
Oh, it's not here.
Now I definitely don't know where I am.
I...
Okay.
All right, we go down.
Or Sipin?
Don't keep me king.
They're king.
Maybe it's here.
Okay, no.
I can still go up.
Wait, there's a down.
Oh, shit!
I wasn't him!
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, I think...
that's also another exploding man yeah yeah never mind it was not the children but it's loot yeah cotton oh my god I paid $90 for one I could have got one for free is there anything up top wee who put spikes on top of an elevator like that's up wait
no I won't go down how do I if I hit left why does it go right all right this way hi hi I'm searching for rare items have you well hands off this collection is mine and I won't be selling a grubby little wonderers so I imagine come across many interesting items in your travels.
It's the anti-hopal spikes.
Yeah, they didn't.
No sleeping on top of the elevators, guys.
Maybe you cared apart with some?
I'll offer a fair trade for each.
Sorry, we're the official symbols.
The king and his knights are long gone.
Wait.
What?
Oh, is this cell?
Oh, this is where I sell this.
Do I sell them?
Must Man, Wakanda's not very inclusive, guys.
Oh, yeah, it's alright.
So it's so for bugs like me to not be able to parkour.
Okay, I'll sell one.
You know the kingdom's five great knights?
They're revered figures of a hollow nest often mentioned in the annals of the...
in the in-house of the kingdom.
Bahoni has a roof.
Both their names and parents seem to have been expunged from history.
So long has passed since their time.
It'd be a grand achievement to discover Daryd Anthony's.
Okay, I'll keep one of them then.
Just for the sake of it.
It's down the city?
Alright, down, I'll go.
Wait, no.
It says up for the city.
Okay.
Wait, up is city?
Wait, what?
Would I go up or down?
What's here?
A mechanism of a simple keyhole.
Oh!
Oh, I don't have the key.
I forgot to buy the key.
I was broke at that time.
I didn't really forgot.
I was just poor.
Oh!
Plot.
Oh, it's a sign for the vendor.
Oh, I see.
Oh, that's me.
Oh, my God.
We can't touch each other.
We touch each other.
We're going to open a paradox.
We're going to make a black hole.
And it'll destroy this land.
Again, we meet little ghost.
I'm you.
But from the future.
From the future past.
wait which one's the real jane silk song the guy she tells you not to worry about again we meet little ghost i'm normally quite perceptive you i underestimate it though i've since guessed the truth you've seen beyond this kingdom's bounds yours is resilience born of two voids it's no surprise then you managed to reach the heart of this world and so doing you shall know the sacrifice that keeps it standing if knowing the truth you still attempt a role in hollow's nest perpetuation seek the grave and ash and the mark it would grant to one like you goodbye me goodbye my future past i'm past future memorial to the hollow night wait that's me that's also me that's john hollow night and the black folk are a above.
Through its sacrifice, Holiness, Last Eternal.
Yeah.
Um.
Wait, do I not go here?
This truly is our Silk Song.
Yeah.
I'm Silk Song.
The prequel.
And she's Silk Song.
The present sequel.
I'm the prequel sequel.
And she's the present sequel.
Alright.
We go.
Where the fuck do I go?
I guess I'll go to the left side.
Just poke go a little bit.
Just because I can.
I don't know where to...
Oh my god, he killed himself.
Please, sir, you have so much to live for.
Is there a map anyway?
Wait, this is where I parkour to higher ground.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I think this is where I parkour to higher ground.
So I can go up now.
Right?
Should go up.
Because, like, I can't go anywhere from the right.
Janelle Smith, where the fuck is that?
He didn't give me a map for that.
Because I can't go anywhere here.
Yeah.
Oh, left was good.
Check map?
Yeah, sure, I'll check the map.
Yeah, let me check the map real quick.
Alright, sorry, but my internet sounds.
So, I can't connect to the GPS, guys.
I...
Sorry, guys.
I have zero bars right now, so I can't connect to GPS.
I can't connect to Google Maps, guys.
I'm sorry.
Oh, this guy...
Oh, it's him.
This has, like, the nail thing.
Oh, shit.
I wanted to kill him.
There you go.
I'm looking at you.
I'm looking at my blank piece of paper.
Like, are you okay, Jane?
Oh, hey.
And not the knife?
Oh, it's more over there.
I was like, why can't I just grab the sword from the ground?
Is that ceiling?
I mean, he's just leaving it there.
It's fine as keepers, you know?
He just leaves it there.
Might as well be mine.
I have no signal, guys.
Have you brought me another nail to be honed?
Leave it on the ground and return later if you're still breathing.
Oh, I thought you were someone else.
After a nail smith, are you?
Well, you found one.
I'm not much for a talk, but if it's a nail that needs repair, then you've come to the right bug.
Your nail is quite a sorry state.
It's obviously not one of mine.
Still, anything can be refined with enough effort and skill.
Even that broken blade.
If you'd like, I can reforge your nail.
I'll make the mint blade far more deadly.
Sure.
It's like $250.
That's like two maps.
Joan shot.
As you wish.
I'll get to work then.
Whoa!
Wait, he just hits it three times.
I could do that.
There we go.
Their forging is complete.
I've honed your nails edge.
You'll find it much stronger than it used to be.
Mr. Miffluffikens, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This truly is our silk song.
Head out there and test his strength against his foes.
Then you do it.
I have an important mission right now.
Like, I don't have the time.
Okay, he needs a pale ore.
Yeah, my blade got a manicure, guys.
How much?
Oh, shit!
Wait!
Oh, now I killed him in two hits.
Check my inventory?
What?
What about my inventory?
I don't fucking know.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
This doesn't kill me.
Wait, what the fuck?
Water doesn't kill me?
That's not accurate.
Water kills so many bugs.
I watched this Twitter clip where it was like, it was so sad.
It was like, it was like these two ants being, like getting titanic.
And then like, uh, it was like these two ants getting titanic as the water slowly and slowly like, um, get closer and closer to them.
And then like, and then one of the ants just literally was like, was just like, like flattened by the water.
away in the ocean in the one got swept away by the current and the other ant like literally just got flattened in the water and just stopped moving i'm like is it okay like i was just like oh my god what happened to it is that is that ant okay you think he made it
i'm gonna try this is that you just what it was a video what do you want me to do like the man the man um the man something like i was like save the ant right now i don't know not watch it it was interesting i was like whoa are they gonna live need us to say they definitely did not live all right see he drowned and oh i'm the bad guy but like why don't i drown he drowned i'm okay thought it was like sonic lure the man the cameraman's manager toky you're so what did i do all i did was watch i was just a bystander that's not evil being a bystander is not evil
It just makes you complicit.
Okay.
I don't know.
Let's keep going up.
How do I do this stupid elevator?
Okay, I'll just do this.
Ow.
That hurt.
That's not nice, buddy.
Alright.
Have you heard the bystander?
Oh, don't act innocent.
You are all bystanders.
You've all done it before.
How do I...
Oh, there we go.
Okay, we go this way.
Let me go up.
Bravo!
Okay, the ones with the little stories are not that scary.
Are not as threatening.
Like, they barely do anything.
Oh, shit!
Nice.
We're fine.
So I got the little bit of their inside juices on me.
That's alright.
Ow.
That's not cool.
Has anyone ever told you that's not cool?
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, we turn this and then get through here.
Now where do we go?
Ow.
Now I'm here.
Okay, so a shortcut.
Oh, I got a shortcut.
Okay, now what do I do?
Oh, we go up here?
Being cool doesn't matter.
He has to do her job, Doki.
Okay.
Surprise, I haven't found Map Man yet.
Where do I go?
Oh, there's a bench up top.
Okay.
I like benches.
There?
No?
Oh, there's the bug.
There's my stipend.
My stipend.
I'm paid by the government.
Don't worry, little guy.
You'll do okay in foster care.
Because I'll be your parent.
Yay.
My government paycheck.
Oh, there he is.
Wait, wait, what?
Okay, I already fought.
I already killed... Yeah, I was gonna say, what the... Oh, there's more.
Oh, it's like...
I was like, that's not scary.
These guys, I've killed him so many times.
Okay, I can heal here.
Oh my god, I can't heal here.
He walks so fast.
Oh, it's just that easy.
It's just three guys.
Turns out, yeah, two waves.
the only evil thing i've done is watching all is watching all the evil things you've done my kamioshi is so evil yeah and you did nothing about it thank you for the super chat that's what i'm saying we're all by standards here All right, time to give.
All right, did the map economy recover, Mr. Cornelius?
This is just a change from the twisting natural caverns.
The raid does cast something of a sadness upon all of the architecture simply slender.
Carding, charting, such a different space is quite the challenge.
The one that we eagerly undertaken.
Perhaps you could have purchased a copy of...
Achievement so far.
Oh, man.
It's going up.
The price is going up.
It stonks up again.
The bubble has recovered.
Oh, my God.
I can finally look at my goddamn stupid map.
Go.
Joey.
Alright, let's go.
We go.
Wait, what?
Ow.
Where are you?
you.
Alright.
He got better.
I was like, wait a minute, I kill you?
Dude, he just got better.
He came back from the hostel just to die again.
Wait, what?
What the fuck is that?
Ow!
Okay, he's a wizard.
Oh, no, not nerds.
My greatest weakness.
Wait, I don't know, like...
Okay.
I'm, like, trying to figure out, like, his patterns.
Oh, alright.
He's a weak...
Oh, like, all magic users, they're weak as hell.
I forgot about that.
They're weak to melee.
So sanctum.
Where the fuck am I now?
That's right.
Your magic means nothing!
When I have Ungabunga.
Where are I?
Go, anyway, I'm gonna go left side first.
What?
What's this?
Wait, this is slop?
God damn, I should have bought the fucking key!
Where is the stack, Peter?
Oh my god.
Can't believe it.
I should have fucking... God damn it.
I should have...
Oh wait, there's a lot here to hit.
I see it.
Oh, secret!
Oh, it's a shortcut!
Oh shit.
The anti-parkour spikes are there.
Yeah, I was gonna say, like, why is he singing?
Oh, I need a different key.
Oh, the key I have wouldn't have worked at any way.
Okay, that's good.
That's good to know.
I'm actually have to have it go all the way down.
I hate the elevators here.
Okay, I'll go this way first.
Magic user.
Ow.
Oh, shit!
God!
Fucking oh my god oh my god the fact that it goes through walls is you're such an asshole
it goes through walls and that's what fucks with me the most
it let's see can't go through here all right can't go through here either so i have to do the parkour thing But it went through the thingy.
It goes through...
Okay, at least it goes through floors.
It goes through floors, I would say.
Oh my god, they're so annoying, though.
The mind still limits us, though.
How did it break past its constraint to take a period of focus?
Is it even possible?
That's disgusting.
Not even Mother can love.
One, two, three.
Where did I open?
Okay, I opened that.
All right, nice.
Oh, I have to go all the way down.
Sorry.
I love him.
Oops.
Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh!
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
What's that?
Guys, don't random break things guys you might not know who it was okay oh my god fuck that was an accident shouldn't have died to that all right nice okay that was easy all right oh my god he learned the nerd learn how to use the sword it's crazy You leveled up.
Oh my god, I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh, you went all the way down here.
You fucking pussy.
That's right.
I don't mind tanking that.
Okay, I don't like this level.
I don't like the magic users here.
The magic users are very annoying.
Okay, that unlocks here.
So what is downstairs?
More magic users, of course.
A fucking curse.
That's what that is.
Of course, that's what's downstairs.
There's more you guys!
Yeah, I'm fine with these.
Filthy mages.
Whoops.
Yeah, the basement nerds.
What's over here?
Oh, it's just shortcut.
Wait, did I unlock it already?
Alright, I do again.
Okay, I did.
Alright.
Go up.
Better not respawn.
I swear to God.
I'm calling their mothers.
Alright, up, up, up.
Down, down, down.
Up.
Andrew, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Alright.
Is it up, I go?
Oh shit!
Where the fuck did he come from?
The guy came from nowhere.
It was like a drive-by.
Uh, no, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Uh, hey Adoki, next time you!
Okay, that's unlocked.
Next time you!
Say that bench, keep trying to equip a talisman, even when your slots are full.
It's a special mechanic?
Wait, what happens if I do that?
Oh my god, of course I miss.
Whoa.
I seriously, I hate you.
I hate you.
Ah!
Where am I?
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'll just tank it.
That's okay.
I don't know what.
I'm like a little lost here.
I can't.
break this.
I don't understand.
Why wouldn't let me break that?
Oh my gosh.
I have a feeling that the boss for this area is very closely related to this magic user.
I'm pretty sure.
Why do you look like Hornet?
I'm playing Silk Song.
I don't understand.
Is this not Silk Sun?
Oh my god, no.
Oh my god, somebody call the Ghostbusters!
We're okay.
There's still more?
Oh, Spell Twister.
What's that?
Blunt Desire the Remaster Improves the Bear's ability to cast spells.
Reduces the Soul Cost.
Oh, okay.
Oh shit.
Oh, so it cost less souls.
Gas spells.
Yeah, I got the early access.
Okay, where is this?
Well, I'll never know where this is.
Okay, down I go.
Oh.
There's a lot of souls here.
Alright.
I have a feeling that that might be a boss fight.
Become the nerd.
Yeah, I'll...
I'll be right back.
Wait, is there something here?
I want to double check.
Alright.
Yeah, not suspicious at all.
Why did it give me three jars of souls?
For free.
Alright.
Guess I'll die.
Hello?
Nerds?
your letter that's it i'm gonna carry this oh that's a big-ass nerd i think oh my god that's a giant nerd i'm down here let me send you to that oh my god oh
okay what stupid nerd
How the fuck do I dodge that?
Excuse me?
Okay, this is actually bullshit.
Like, I don't know.
Like, I don't know what to do.
Like, am I even allowed to heal?
Nope.
Alright, there we go.
That's fine.
could have killed but i i had like other things to worry about here
jesus christ oh my god oh my god i hate you
i oh my god the bait are you serious are you fucking Are you kidding me?
Yeah, of course that doesn't hit.
A fucking course.
Okay, nice.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I gotta be super patient here.
when he does these stupid spells.
Okay.
That's...
I'm not using magic.
He is, like, way too...
He's way too, like...
He moves, like, way too fast to use spells.
This guy?
Oh, my God.
Wait, first try?
That's right.
Get in the locker, nerd.
That's fucking right.
I'm going to give you a goddamn swirly.
No magic's going to fucking save you.
Oh, no.
It's the second phase two.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
I'm just joking.
I was just joking.
I didn't hit me.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
It didn't mean it Oh my god.
Oh my god the nerds fighting back the nerds fighting back
It was just a joke.
I'm sorry.
I was just joking No, you're really great
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I can't do that heal.
That's way too risky.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, it's just I accidentally bounced into him.
Okay.
I'm like trying to figure out when I can heal.
God damn it.
I don't know.
Okay, that's good.
I get, like, one heal.
I'm fine with that.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
That's right.
Now we take you to the swirly.
Get over here.
I'm going to dunk your head.
That's right.
I'm going to heal real quick.
quick now it's first try get dunk nerd tapby replenish your okay oh so it's like what like how do i use it how do i use it no wait what how do i use it
Oh, I see.
Okay, is that even good?
Whoops.
I used up all my souls for that.
Oopsie.
I gotta recharge.
He had invincibility frames?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, so that's what it was for.
The breaking thing.
Oh.
What the fuck is this ghost doing here?
It's so hard to get it right I'm having trouble like I'm having trouble getting it to work
Yeah I just can't I'm holding down!
I swear to God!
I swear to God, I'm holding down.
I'm not fucking with you guys.
I'm holding down.
I swear.
I swear to God I need more souls.
But I thought there was one guy over here.
I'm holding B.
I swear!
I swear to God, I'm holding V.
Oh, I don't need a jump.
Oh my God, I'm so stupid.
I thought I needed to jump.
I...
Wait, what do I do?
I'm stuck here.
Okay, good.
We actually need this or I'll be like softlocked.
Wait, what?
There we go.
Okay, I figured it out.
I was...
I didn't need a jump.
It does work mid-air.
I don't know how.
See?
I don't understand.
Please.
Wait, where am I now?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of here.
No!
Where?
Oh, okay, thank God I spawned here.
I first tried a boss, but I got killed by a little ghosty man.
You're so strong.
These little ghosty men.
Oh, hey, there's a...
Oh my god, please.
Please, please, please free me.
There we go.
How do I get out of here?
My one fear are these ghosty mans.
They are the hardest boss in this game.
They didn't warn me that these will be the hardest boss in silk styling.
Nice.
$20 from the government.
Let's go.
Alright.
Go up.
Jesus Christ!
That's not fair!
I wasn't ready for that.
Wait, what's over on the left side, actually?
I didn't go fully up, I think.
Or did I?
Oh, I did.
Yeah, there's nothing here.
Except for that one little guy.
Alright.
Nice, we're out of here.
Did I finish this area?
Okay.
Was Magic Man the last guy?
The only boss in this area, chat?
Or let's practice.
Okay, we did it.
Okay, I'm getting better.
Alright, guys, I'm getting better at it.
See, it's just like the wall riding.
I got better.
It's just...
It's just like the wall riding.
We got better at it.
Eventually.
Gotta get out of here.
I got it.
I figured it out.
I downloaded the algorithm.
Oh, I just didn't have enough.
I was like, do I not download the algorithm?
I just didn't have enough.
Spirit of God, these guys are harder than the fucking boss I fought.
Because, like, they teleport more than the other guy.
They actually teleport more.
Wait, why did I go back here?
I don't understand.
Did I finish that?
Oh, wait.
Oh, that was the shortcut area.
Now what do I do?
That beat it?
I don't know.
Like, oh, I got what I need?
Okay.
I'm gonna go back to the bench then.
It's here, right?
Okay, here we go.
All right.
Oh, he's gone.
Sorry, I didn't see you.
If you lost, why not pop up because I started and did not purchase a map of this area available now for an excellent price.
All right.
I'm done with this area.
I feel like I explored most of everything except for it here.
Assume this is like...
Yeah, this is how to get home.
Okay.
I mean, there is an area bottom okay I'm gonna check what bottom right is the conifer 8 is insane he deserves it all right nice this way here no that's where I got the I would go down that didn't get me whoops this way no It's just to the right.
I haven't been here, I think.
Oh, I can't go here, anyway.
I was like, oh, I haven't been here.
JK.
There was just no option for me to go there.
Alright.
Let's go up.
Up again.
And then...
To the left.
What for having a hot?
way.
No, for having a fucking monopoly on maps.
I'm tired of this map capitalism.
Sometimes I don't want to participate in capitalism.
Watch where you're going, man.
You soggy vagabond.
I don't want you splashing on me.
I've had a miserable time trying to keep dry.
I play game to escape.
Not contribute to a goddamn monopoly.
I am so mighty.
Knight of Green Renown.
If I decide that I'm going to stay dry, man, then that's what's going to happen.
Curse this wretched city.
Water and monster constantly fall from above.
It's no wonder this plastic kingdom falls to ruin.
No, she saved him.
What's wrong with him?
a jolly old man.
He just seems like a boomer.
Where am I?
I like how that guy threw a spike and I'm just looking at my map, ignoring him.
Just like, where did I go?
He's like, I'm gonna get him.
I'm like, where am I?
Go up.
Okay, there's bench up here
wait what how do i get that oh
my god they have anti-poor core up there too i can't have anything ow okay oh my gosh i couldn't fucking use my hp no i spammed the magic accidentally wait oh wait there's a item here i must have grabbed that at first
What's that?
Alright.
What did I get?
What is that?
Joe left behind by long-dead traveler.
The words are written in a forgotten dialect and difficult to understand.
It holds low value except for those dedicated to the kingdom's history.
Oh, I can...
Wait, I can read it?
No, I can't.
I'm illiterate.
My bug is illiterate.
Okay, he doesn't need a read.
He just got...
She just got to look pretty for silk sign.
Oh, there we go.
There's the stag.
Okay, got the couch.
I mean, got the bench.
Alright, time to pay for this, too.
Let's take all my money, I guess.
Oh.
But I can afford stuff.
I can afford the key now.
Alright, I need to go up top.
Yo.
Open several stack stations now, haven't you?
I'm thankful for the opportunity.
As I visit more places, I feel my memories returning to me.
Like the stack waves of my mind are running once more.
Continue to open the station, and you'll have my deepest gratitude.
Alright, let's buy some upgrades.
I can get a key from free?
Alright, first I left by.
What?
Let's buy.
Let's see what good things they have.
I mean, I could.
It's 150.
It's not that much.
Nice.
Yeah!
Uh...
Oh, wait.
I can...
What's that?
What do I get?
Do I get a key?
I'll get a key, actually.
Uh...
I mean, I could just buy all of these.
Yay!
Another mask.
This?
Vessel fragment?
Oh, I guess that gives me more stuff I can equip for charms.
Alright, spent all my money.
Alright, so we need...
City store room.
You guys said I can grab a key at the bottom?
Where's the key?
Wait, do I have more soul slot, uh, charm slots?
No, I don't.
I'm still fucking poor.
Where's the key?
Oh, did y'all lie to me?
A load of city storerooms.
Where the fuck is that?
Go down then, right?
Okay, I'm gonna check what's over here.
What's this?
Toll symbol.
Wait, what?
Or what?
What do I need that for?
Oh my god.
Now I need a fucking...
I spent all my money.
Go down.
It's another shortcut.
Oh.
Then where?
Then left or right?
Okay, I need money, so I'm gonna kill you.
I'm gonna rob you real quick.
I'm gonna mug you.
Get over down from here.
I need to mug you.
Ow.
Get down from here.
Come on, you can't keep throwing these sticks all day.
There we go.
Thanks for the money.
Oh, shit!
Oh, hey, shortcut.
I'm gonna shake you.
I'm gonna mug you real quick.
Oh, I can't go down right yet.
Okay.
I want to grab the toll first.
Oh, shit.
What's over here?
Why were there a bunch of them down here?
Alright.
Crime core.
Oh, hey, what's this?
Hey, what's this?
There's just a random tree down here.
What is that?
What is this?
Why is there a tree?
Oh, it's for later?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I was like, why is there a random tree here?
Who let this tree be here?
Oh, I forgot to unlock this door.
Oh, it's just more backtracking stuff.
Oh, yeah, for my...
The Metrovania part.
Alright.
Like, don't worry about it.
What if I want to worry about it?
What do you mean?
That means there's something to worry about.
I wasn't worrying about it.
Now I am.
This top, right?
Oh, this guy.
I'm just going to force it.
Alright.
Oh, I got this key.
Wait, I got another key?
Wait, does anyone remember where the locked door is?
Because I did not mark it.
Alright, guys.
It's time to find out.
Guys, where is the...
Alright, where is the door?
Is it this door?
Oh, it's this door.
Okay.
It's right here.
I remember now.
It's this door.
Okay, we can go there.
Can I open that door now?
Ow.
Oh, not that door?
Which door?
Which one?
If it's not this door?
It's not that one?
Then which door do I open?
Near the nail smith?
There's a door near the nail smith?
I don't remember no door.
Oh, this door?
Down.
Oh, this over here.
Okay.
Yeah, we can do that.
Let me open the...
Let me open the other door for so many doors.
Okay, I'm going to open this door first.
I open this door and then we'll go to the other door.
Yes, please.
What happens here?
Oh my god, that's a giant-ass door.
Alright.
I don't know where it takes me.
Where am I?
Oh, yeah.
in where am i oh i'm over here oh okay all right that's where i am
i'm below the dirt man oh now i can go left okay i'll do that again i was like oh yeah this place where am i I have, there's loot over here.
Okay, let's check it out.
Where am I?
Oh, there's a depressed man.
Don't worry, I'll put you out in your misery, guys.
Ow!
Wait, you can just do that?
Oh, shit!
Wait, that's illegal.
Yeah.
I'll go this way first.
That really parkour when I'm just going to go straight.
Oh, there's the loot.
Oh, I should really heal.
What did I get?
Oh, it's another soul fragment thing.
Okay, nice.
Dippy loot.
Mostly use spells for the boss fights, because they're like, they do more damage from what I've noticed.
there's nothing here so I'll just go this way down I go down I go all right time to open that door now I'll collect my government paycheck later I gotta go to that sewer area it's not here
Wee!
Wait.
Which is faster.
Okay, this way is faster.
Yeah, I'll collect the welfare later.
For fostering these children.
Oh, she's gonna love the sewers.
I have a feeling that means I might not love it.
I swear, is it a poison sewer, guys?
Is it a poison sewer?
Is that why I'm gonna love the sewer?
Every time they put, like, a sewer level, it's usually poison.
Or rats.
It's one or the other.
Gee, thank you for the five gift of chips.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
All right, down I go.
Wee.
Oh, shortcut.
I don't even know this side area.
all right well nope nope down down no down down good boy I said down down okay now where do I go it's this way okay it's not this way oh my god oh my god I'm gonna die to a regular thing that was close that was so close I got a loss.
I was like, where am I?
Okay, down.
No!
Okay, down, yeah.
Okay, it's this way.
So I had to, like, double-check.
Alright, now!
We got the key!
Okay, we figured it out.
I have no data.
I have no signal down here.
My map GPS isn't working.
this is bad I literally zero data in my map GPS what the fuck what is that are those worms
oh my god what the fuck is that okay I got Pogo these guys oh my god of course they're down here too
It's a bug, dokey.
Yeah, oh, oh my god, really?
Oh my god, a bug in my hollow knight?
Sorry, my silk song game?
Ooh, that's odd.
Oh, wait.
Okay, there's a bench here.
That's good.
I actually really need a bench.
Where am I?
Oh, there it is.
What do you mean map updated?
What do you mean?
What am I drawing for?
What am I drawing?
I just drawing a fucking smiley face?
I don't like this sound.
Oh my god.
I do not like these enemies.
Okay, there's two of them.
They're like little dogs.
It's like map updated as I just drew a smiley face on the piece of paper.
Okay.
Wait, that's where I went.
That's, like, where I got the bench.
I guess I can check if there's anything here.
Anything here?
What the fuck?
Oh, it's like a little pufferfish.
Look at that.
I'm playing pool.
Oh, shit.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Oh, shit.
Okay, I can swim.
That's good.
I'll just swim.
It's okay.
I can float.
That feels a lot more convenient.
I feel like I have to parkour here.
Why did he get over here?
Yeah, I was gonna say, how did you get over here?
I think what sucks is that it doesn't bounce back when I- oh shit.
It doesn't bounce back when I hit him.
Yeah, that's like really annoying.
Oh my god, get out of here.
We're still alive?
Oh, he played dead.
What?
Okay, okay.
Okay, that's not fair.
Should have been dead.
I hate...
I hate the sound.
He's like...
He's like, he's choking.
Okay, the map guy has to be here.
I'm following his paper trail.
He's leaving a paper trail of maps for me.
I don't know exactly where, though, after that.
Oh my god.
No!
I was doing so well!
Where the fuck am I?
Alright, just keep going left.
Okay.
I'll just keep flying.
Oh hey, what's this?
Yay!
I got full mask.
Oh, next you're here.
I got full HP.
But how the fuck do I get back up top?
Guess I'll go.
Oh, do I have to go the long way?
I don't think I can get back up top there.
Yeah, I don't think so.
Because it's that, uh...
I feel like...
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
What the...
Is that another fact?
Oh my god, it's another Rancid.
I have to pay for that, too.
I don't even know what they're for.
Oh, yeah, I had to do this again.
It's a walk of shame.
Oh, technically I don't even have to kill him.
Okay, maybe I have to kill this.
Oh, wait, no, I can't.
No, I...
Map fun, SXR.
They give them a Jetta Supa.
Thank you.
I can find this fucker.
Okay, it's this way.
Is it this way?
Okay.
Gotta follow the trail.
The map trail.
Eat the money, too.
Are you serious?
No!
Stupid.
Oh, and you're gonna fly!
The fact that the puffer, the puffer bug was like, I'm not done with you.
The fact that he came back to is like, I'm not done with you.
It follows.
God, I hate this area so much.
How dare you touch.
He touched me!
I was the one that did not consent.
Oh, God these guys are no wonder you guys were like oh you're gonna love this area you're gonna love it oh you're gonna love this area but you're gonna love it so much
my god they're following me too oh my god I wasn't even the one that inflated you yeah just don't touch the dokey is that easy
I don't even want to touch them that's not even the worst part of the sewage these guys fucking suck all
right get over here knew it going this way now get
out of here I know you're alive.
I fought like 20 of you.
You don't have to play dead.
He's like, no, she's not gonna expect it.
Another resident.
Oh my god, I could have done that.
I could have just done that.
Oh my god, where is he?
How do I, how do I get up there?
Oh, the gates are locked!
How do you- Oh, is it an arena?
Oh, I have to kill everything here.
Okay.
I was so confused.
I was like, where do I go?
Okay, I'll do one by one.
Okay, that's fine.
I mean, I literally just gotta do it slow but slow and steady.
It's murder time.
This guy, though.
And this guy.
Wait, I still...
It's still three hits, even with magic?
You would think it'd be like...
I thought it'd be like...
Like...
Less hits.
Alright, let's get our goddamn maps.
Oh, aren't these wateries saving?
A labyrinth of pipes and...
Time notice.
I couldn't ask for a better place to employ my talents.
It's so, so orderly, so considered.
Nothing like the crude irregularities of those caverns.
That was so sad in my trunk.
It's telling me those fungal ways are close, and I sense my deep, amp adventure may have reached this end.
Guess I'll be calling this map done.
You didn't even...
I was the one that updated this map.
What the fuck do you mean?
gonna call it done i did like 99 of this work yeah i need a where's my marker okay i need to get rid of my marker it's bothering me all right where do i go i just have to go right now oh whoops i'm actually i literally did all that work he's like whoops i i did it guys like what the do you mean you did it Oh my god,
I was literally, like, right there.
That's, like, that's the worst part.
I'm gonna go the easy way.
Fuck this.
I'm not dealing with the goddamn inflatable...
Inflatable Settlement.
Inflatable bendy arms.
McGee over there.
It's gonna do it this way.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Oh, I have to go down from this way.
That's fine.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, I know that magic doesn't matter for these guys.
Because they do the same.
It does the same damage.
Alright, where do I go?
Okay, I can go down.
Okay.
I go down.
Okay, I'm going to rest real quick.
Go rest, and then I can go down again.
Okay, get up.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Shut the fuck up.
Okay, where's another down?
Yeah?
Oh, it's here.
That's not right.
Thank you for the super chat.
You.
Yay, map pun.
They get rid of the secret chat thingy thing.
Oh, my God.
Whoops.
Look out there.
I want...
I try to be fancy.
Alright, now what?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
You see...
I got...
My reflexes got the better of me.
I was like, it's done exploding!
It was not done exploding.
Alright.
didn't correct me.
Oh, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
No, get me out of here.
Get me out of No, just stupid bug.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
It's fine.
Come on.
All right.
We're good.
We're okay.
so much.
Okay, so clearly there's something on up top that I missed.
Oh, this is a boss fight.
Why would there be so many dead bodies?
This is a boss fight room, isn't it?
Oh my god.
There's too many dead bodies for my liking.
Oh, Oh my god, there's a lot of dead bodies here.
I don't like it.
I hate these worms so much.
I hate them.
I hate them so much.
Why do they exist?
Oh my god, I already forgot that.
These stupid flying turnip.
are the bane of my existence these goddamn turnips
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh shit get him out of here I'm
okay I'm okay I'm I'm alive I'm alive I don't know How I live there, but I'm alive
Okay, I got my money too
Holy shit This area fucking sucks You're right You're right This is the worst one so far This is absolutely the worst one Oh Oh Oh Like, I don't know which one is, like, background, and which one is it.
The fact that they can climb on walls is the worst part.
Yeah, no, this is the worst one so far.
100%.
I don't like these worms.
Any worms are disgusting.
Like, these hurt me, right?
Oh, they don't even hurt me.
I'm just killing babies for no reason.
You know what?
No, they deserve it.
They deserve it.
I'm killing the babies for the actions of their of the adults
They deserve it your parents is you died because it's your parents fault Just for the thrill Your parents caused this So I must kill you Toki knows yeah killing the innocence for the crimes of your ancestors yes 100% I agree with that philosophy all right where does this lead me this leads me all the what the fuck what was the point what was the point are you serious oh my god i am gonna kill all the kids i breakable what
I don't see any breakable wall.
Oh, up left?
Oh my god, there it is.
There it is.
Oh my god, that was actual fucking bait.
I'm mad.
All children deserves to die now.
what's that what's the sound of that come on get up get up don't play dead don't fucking fuck with me right now oh shit
can I kill it from here Jesus how do I kill it how
the fuck do you kill What's that?
Slowly.
Yeah, I guess I just have to dodge this shit, then.
What's this?
Okay, let's hope that I go the right way.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, it's fine.
I tanked it.
It's fine, I tanked it.
I don't know which way is the right way okay it's not that way
Oh now this is the boss fight This is bad because it's like I'm in the water Oh no I'm fine I'm in the junk pit Never mind Cocoon chained with a simple dock Wait though not yet let me explore this first before They, like, go and kill me, I guess.
Alright.
I guess our time to die.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Yoink.
Mine now.
She can't fight back.
The god turner.
Seek the gods of hollowness, tune their power through their strength, ascend.
What the fuck?
What the fuck did you give me?
Is that it?
Oh, hey.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Free money.
Oh, I found the DLC.
Oh, my God.
So I was here for no reason.
How do I get out?
Bro, she trapped me in here.
How did I get here?
Oh, I gotta go here.
Okay.
I was gonna say like...
I'm at DLC and I can't even leave!
Okay, it's this way.
I can parkour at least.
Okay, nice.
I'm trapped in here with her.
And now where am I?
Hello?
Oh, I'm at the fungal area.
I made it all the way to the fungal area.
What the fuck?
I thought I was in the sewage.
Sounds like a win for me.
Just don't know where I am.
I gotta find a bench.
Okay, this is a shortcut to somewhere.
What the fuck?
I'm here.
here now?
What the fuck?
Alright, I guess I have to go back to the sewers.
I'm at the nail sniff, but like, it's no use because I can't even upgrade anything.
Yeah, it was one giant loop.
Well, technically, oh my gosh.
Technically, it can't even do anything.
Because the loop, I can't go, I can't use it to go back.
I have to go through the sewer from down here.
Yeah, he drowned himself.
Let's go.
Yeah, I don't have any... I don't think I do.
Alright, time to go back to the worm there.
Okay.
Let me figure out how to do this again.
Have I gone here before?
God damn it.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I'm just gonna get rid of them because they're so annoying.
Yeah, he deserved it.
He deserved to drown.
We all saw him.
He was an asshole.
Nobody will remember him.
Wait, do I go here?
Oh, here.
Okay, I haven't gone this way yet.
Yeah, I haven't gone this way.
on this way i think yeah look not all bug lives matter that's why i said it especially hornets fuck hornets i say as i'm pointed who said that whoa hornets are invasive species they do not provide anything this world.
What the fuck is talking to me?
They're like, but like I don't see anything.
Is he up top?
Oh he's up.
He's like, he's so calm.
What's that?
Hello?
Mera, Mera, Akko!
Mera, Akko.
Ah, yeah?
Red oh oh oh, it was not friendly.
It was not friendly.
It was bait.
Don't defend.
I'm in shit.
I'm in just  little shit!
It's just shit.
Okay.
It's just  Okay.
It's just shit.
okay we're we're just in the world of shit that's why we're in the sewers that makes a lot of sense actually are you
ha ha ha ha yippee shit oh fucking course it hits me there oh my god are you serious now he does like breaststrokes Oh my god.
He fucking does breaststrokes now.
Oh my god, I hate you.
So much.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We gotta come down soon.
Oh my god, that should not have hit me.
No!
Oh my god, I almost hit him.
Okay, I'm just gonna heal the next time I hit him in a...
If I hit, like, a...
Instead of, like...
Okay, I'm worried he's gonna do it with a fucking goddamn breaststroke again.
No!
Okay, that's good.
Okay, nice.
I heal.
I had a heal.
Yeah, this move...
This moves...
Shit.
Yeah, pun not intended.
And if I feel all...
Yes, no!
No!
Oh my god!
That was not...
I think I can get a heal here.
Yeah.
Nice.
what is
he doing what is that what is that move oh okay he just he's just faster okay that's what it is okay nice okay nice just a little faster that's fine okay
i'm just gonna do magic here
There's so many things going on with me!
Nice.
Okay.
I just have to be next to him when he does that.
So I can grab a hit.
Oh!
I'm lucky.
I think I didn't heal here.
Nice.
And then it's just basketball.
Dodge the boss!
Okay.
Are you serious?
Nice.
Oh, first try!
Okay, this is pretty easy.
That's right.
Fuck off.
Get out of here.
I'm the baller now.
What's this?
Unique charm bestowed by the king of Holonice to his most loyal not scratched and dirty, but still.
Causes a bear to evoke admit a heroic what the fuck does that do what does it mean when I get a heroic odor like what does that even mean I just get like a fart aura it just makes me stinky what's the point of that
look Doki you're gonna get aura okay that's the point
You just don't understand.
It's all about the aura.
It's what the kids call aura.
Okay, what's down there, though?
I'm curious.
Oh, it's just spikes.
But there is money here.
And money is always good.
Oh, there's more money.
Okay.
Nice.
No, what do you think of the game so far?
Are you having fun?
Yeah.
I like the boss fights.
The boss fights are fun.
Do I go down or up, chat?
I can't tell.
I legitimately can't tell.
Yeah we farm the aura from that boss.
Down looks more and more scary for some reason.
Down is looking very ominous right now.
Oh, hey, there's a tree again.
I can't do anything with this tree.
Up if you want the bed.
Oh, my God.
Give me a sec.
I gotta go back up.
I gotta go get the bench.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I know what.
Actually, what the fuck?
Wait, how do I get back up?
Don't you...
I don't know.
That's what I'm saying.
and down?
Wait, I can't go back up.
Wait, how do I... Oh, okay, wait, wait, okay, I figured it out.
Okay.
Okay, that's how you go back up.
Okay, we're gonna grab the bench first before we do this.
Alright.
A slow, uphill battle.
oh my god wait is this good okay i was gonna say can i use that wall as a platform i can
where's the bench city of tears where's the bench hello bench doko hello i was promised a bench okay i wasn't promised this guy i was promised a fucking bench guys
the left?
Okay, goodbye, sir.
I do not care about you.
Okay, so there's a bench here.
Where the fuck is this bench?
That was promised.
Let me just kill some of the civilians real quick.
No!
Bench is right, not left?
Oh my god.
it who was that guy give me his name and then we'll ban him he's gotta learn what was his name oh my god nice carry for me and shit okay who was the one guy i got one guy give me his name come on write him out write him out if i got one guy find that guy right now out god
damn it this guy is so annoying i hate him holy shit how how many hits oh my god i give up
i hate this guy there's so many of them there is actually so many of them there's so strong no imagine how much money i'll get though i have to kill him i'd get so much money if i kill him though that's the thing I have to.
Oh my god, I fell into him.
Wait, he does two damage?
Okay, maybe not.
Maybe.
Okay, but I could get so much money, though.
How much was it?
Oh, it was just $50.
Okay, never mind.
It was not worth it.
I just noticed.
Guys, it was not worth it.
I only got $50.
I'm just gonna kill the civilian.
Okay, there's a sag area here soon.
That's over there.
Wait, what the fuck?
Are you fucking kidding me?
They could just do that?
They broke the bench?
What?
What happened to my chair?
ring ring ring oh it's up okay it's up okay i was like they can just do that just just break the public transport
okay there's an upper one okay
nice all right nice okay now i'll go down okay do we stay up here do we go down oh my god it's getting this is such a breach this is like This is uptown.
Don't forget to equip your new gamer aura at the bench.
Also, to try and equip more charms past your charm slot for the hidden mechanic.
Wait, what is the hidden mechanic?
The stack inflation.
What was it?
Is it this one?
It won't let me equip it.
Alright, I want to see what this is.
So how do I throw away items?
So guys, how do you throw away items?
Oh, I have to...
Oh, okay, so I have to equip it past the slot.
Alright, what's the hidden mechanic?
It just gives me a purple.
What does that mean?
That's it.
Alright.
The aura farm is...
Okay, guys, do I...
Wait, is this still the rich area?
Yeah, it is.
Okay, do I go back to the sewer area?
Oh, we have to keep spamming it?
Okay.
I didn't know that.
I could do that.
Okay.
I gotta do it, like, three times?
Overtime.
Guys, did I...
It feels like I broke the game.
What happens when I'm overcharged?
Doesn't look too bad.
Oh, the damage.
Okay, yeah, no.
That's pretty bad.
I don't want to get double damage.
Things happen.
No, that's okay.
No, that's alright.
Okay, guys.
Do we go back down or do we stay in here?
Smile.
Don't fucking out.
yeah you knew what was gonna happen who spoiled it it was gonna happen I was gonna find out eventually guys in one second I was gonna find out literally one second okay we'll go down oh go left to open the door and connect the two has.
Oh yeah, I forgot about that.
We will have fun for one.
Yeah, but that means we will have fun for one second.
It's not even worth it.
Snitches get stitches but also in exchange for more damage, you get to equip extra charms for more powerful builds and not just a troll.
Now, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, it's alright.
I like that it's one damage that they do to me.
I like having them do only one damage instead of double.
That seems a lot of fun in general.
Okay, it's down here.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I connected the two halves.
That's right.
I invited a Polterrier into it.
The bullet bourgeoisie.
What you gotta do about that?
Viva de France!
That's right, you rich bugs.
Can't stay there forever.
I was pointing him to go wherever and you'll find stuff to do.
You have access to almost the entire map.
Explore and have fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's still...
I think again, it's still for the super chat.
What the fuck?
Polterriot versus the bourgeoisie.
Bravo!
I connected the two cities together.
They didn't want it.
But it don't matter what they think.
Alright.
We go this way now.
This place looks very dangerous.
It looks very ominous.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I was like, what's below me?
Oh, okay.
Death.
I wonder what's below me right now.
Do you think it's...
safe for me?
Just actual death down there.
It's over here, though.
Okay.
What is that?
Oh, money.
Someone's secret stash.
Oh, I thought there'd be a secret there.
God damn it.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
Fuck.
Oh, hey.
Speed run.
That is intentional.
There's nothing here.
You'd think there'd be something down there.
What's down here?
What the fuck?
Oh my gosh, no map.
Nope.
I'm making them some for a side of some kind of pass.
Fuck am I.
Where the fuck am I?
Yeah, but there's a hole here.
Huh?
Pull left.
Before I go?
Hello?
Get down, I go.
Get over here.
Oh, shit, JK!
He's like, you told me to get that over here.
Jesus Christ!
What is this guy's range?
Oh my god!
That guy's range was insane.
Wait, what's down over here?
Okay, I need a...
Yeah, far more solos.
Okay, that's enough solos.
That should be enough.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I can hit it, and then he go back.
Yeah, because He has like...
Okay, nice.
But I'm gonna check time.
Okay, now I know how to fight these guys.
Yeah.
I hear like the explodey guys.
Dude.
I hear the explodey guys near me.
I know they're here.
What the fuck is that?
What?
It's just orange ghoul.
Are those bees?
Oh, it's these guys.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, these guys are weak as hell though.
Does that mean the next boss is like themed around these guys?
Oh, wait.
They spit those too.
They...
Oh, god damn it!
Fuck this, I'm Pogo-ing.
No!
I missed my Pogo.
What?
Meryl?
Oh, no, it's that girl.
It's cloth.
My friend.
You tell with all these beasts?
I'm chain of sea.
I was hiding.
Those ghastly things chased me.
And I ran.
I hadn't come along.
Who knows if I ever have survived.
others take me for a fearsome warrior what with my impressive size was this kingdom's beast I wonder if I'm just no match for them don't worry you got this buddy just squish them they like that enough I cannot wallow in my weakness I must take strength from you example you act so confident in battle you show no fear before your foes I'll try my best to do the same Alright,
cool.
Are you not gonna help me?
Why won't you help me?
I literally gave you, like...
I gave you motivation.
Help me.
Help me fight them.
Like, he's literally...
Oh, my god.
Wait, are these, like...
Like, what the fuck?
Help me fight them.
these guys.
I'll meet her again.
Nice.
She better help me.
What's this?
Oh, nice.
I can upgrade.
That's good.
I got upgrades now.
Fucking new.
Oh, I can shoot it.
Wait.
Fuck.
I should have done that before.
Oh, no.
I knew that before.
Okay, now I get to have...
Oh, never mind.
That didn't work the second time.
Never mind.
It didn't work.
I thought I was so clever.
I was like, look, I did it.
Does this have a map?
No, it doesn't.
God damn, of course it doesn't.
Nothing ever has a map.
They never have a map.
That's me.
Alright.
It does, but you have to be free.
Am I done with that area?
I can't tell because like I can't see anything.
My GP, I don't have signal down here.
So I can't tell.
Ancient Basin.
This is suck when you just don't have signal.
Oh my god, thank god.
At least you're here.
Well, Gavin, he's on.
the weight of the kingdom above.
It's a heavy thing, all right.
I reckon not many reach these depths.
We pioneers, you and I, at least in recent history.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I'll take a map.
Thank you.
I'm literally holding up your GDP right now.
Alright, there is a bench to the left side.
We're gonna grab that.
There's something I wanted.
Oh, yeah.
I gotta go to the weapons, man.
so far though I'll do that later weapon man too far
yes give me my bench pay the bench I would like my pay the bench please thank you nice all right the gray button is so far I have to go so far I'll Do it when I find a fucking subway.
I'll do it when I find the MTR.
Maybe it's over here.
It's just too far right now.
I need to find the MTR for this area.
No, MTR at a metro station.
Wait, how do I...
How come I can't do this?
The stag station.
I can't get to the palace grounds.
Alright, absorb the souls.
Wait, what's this?
Our beings, these words are for you alone.
Our pure vessel has ascended.
Beyond lies only the refuse and regret of its creation.
We shall center that place no longer.
Huh?
Lore!
Oh, I need double trap, uh, double jump.
Okay, so I can't head there yet.
Am I supposed to be down here?
Come back later?
Where do I go to come back later?
Do I have to go?
Am I supposed to be in this area?
Can't tell.
No, you're not?
Okay, let's leave.
Alright, time to leave.
Ow.
Gotta fuck this guy.
Okay, now we leave.
Alright, how do I leave?
It's this way.
I don't want to deal with this guy.
Crystal mines.
Where the fuck is that?
Guys, I don't know where the crystal mines.
How do I get to the crystal mines?
Oh, wait.
Okay, let me...
From here...
tears.
Oh, the right of crossroads?
Okay, grab that.
I get out of here.
I need to take your stash.
Guarding your stash of money.
You're so greedy.
Can't believe it, and you're not gonna share with me?
It's this way.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Alright.
Oh my god, okay.
Can't believe I have to go all the way back.
Oh!
It's so far!
Parkour!
Okay.
Ow.
I gotta make sure I don't die from this.
Gotta do the parkour.
Parkour.
Yeah, I'm going all the way back up top so I can upgrade the nail.
Are you serious?
Get out of here!
You took your lives don't matter!
We can replace you whenever we want!
Okay, this way.
I'm having so much fun, Parkway.
Alright.
I'm bugging.
Lives matter.
Not all bug lives matter.
I can name like so many...
That's right, you deserve to drown.
I can name so many bugs that contribute nothing to society.
Get this way.
No real.
If it matters so much, why would you need...
Why would you need mosquito spray, huh?
Why don't you just let the mosquitoes suck your blood?
They're hardworking single mothers.
You know the mosquitoes that suck your blood, they're all hardworking single mothers trying to provide for their kids.
Oh, but you won't let them suck your blood.
What's wrong with that?
True.
That's okay, you're right.
So not all bug lives matter.
That's fucking right.
Let them suck your blood.
Why are you fucking using mosquito nets, huh?
Because I need my blood.
You just want to take a little bit.
0.1% of your blood.
I don't want malaria.
Oh, so you want her to starve?
Would you love dragoons if we were bugs, don't you?
No comment.
you for this super chat no thank you thank you
all right i got i see you have some pale ore a rare fine metal that give me the ore and some geo for your efforts i'll reinforce your nail to make it strong all right nice oh i don't have enough goo oh i sorry geo okay it's fine i can farm it what we're especially not worms all right i gotta farm god damn it why did you have to kill yourself How am I gonna rob you if you're dead?
Oh my god, I need like 800.
It's gonna take fucking forever to fire.
Where can I farm this, actually?
Yeah, you're right.
I have to sell the emblems.
I'm gonna go sell it.
I don't think I can farm this.
Farm it from just tier fighting.
I'm at 700.
These guys take that...
These guys are 10, so I just need to kill 10 of them.
I'll just sell it from...
Oh, wait.
There's a merchant.
Oh, the merchant's above me.
Sell it from the merchant, then.
Alright, take my money.
Sell me objects.
Um, am I...
Can I sell the journal to him?
Am I...
Yeah?
Okay.
A wonder is journal, eh?
Although they're common fountains about the kingdom.
I much enjoyed the deciphering of their text.
Road together.
They read together.
They paint a morbid tale.
It seems fate wasn't kind to those most who travel within Holiness ruins.
Alright, now I can afford it.
No, I will not sell.
I'm a hoarder.
I'm hoarding it for Silk Song, too.
Because this is silk song.
Don't worry, my money will transfer over in silk song too.
I know, good decision, I know.
Smart.
Okay.
All right, I gotta go to the nail man.
Take my money nail man.
Okay, we're almost there.
All right.
hello yes take my money take my goo sorry my geo i always feel i keep thinking it's that it's right says goo all right nice whack whack whack only rancid eggs transfer this song too sorry toky thank you for the soup you don't know that you don't know that We're gonna find out in 10 years If we will Okay,
how strong is it now?
One, two, three Oh, shit, it's pretty strong Yeah, it's three strikes now That's pretty fucking strong I check my inventory Why?
I don't remember what my knife Used to look like, I'm sorry If you're like You're like asking me to check how it looks like I actually, I don't remember what it's supposed to look like i'm sorry to me it just looks the same i it would change it looks the same to me i you're like oh my god check it out look how different it is i'm like different
a knife is a knife
okay this way and then we go up Yay!
And then we go.
Nope, nope, nope.
Up.
Oh, that's as high as I could go.
Okay, I was gonna say, keep going up!
But it couldn't keep going up.
I went this way.
God damn it, these guys.
God damn it.
Get out of here.
I gotta heal.
Okay, they said still take only two strikes, though.
Okay, forgotten crossroads is up here.
Alright.
We gotta go.
Up.
Jesus Christ.
Get out of here!
The king doesn't care about you!
Just work.
You don't have to go overtime.
You don't have to try as hard.
You're never gonna get that promotion.
Mike, thank you for this, uh, for the one gift of ship, thank you, thank you.
Wait, there's a stack station over there?
Why the fuck?
Oh my god, I should have bought the stack station shit.
You know what, I need to go to the stack station anyway.
Alright.
Oh shit, my map updated?
See, it all looks the same.
Okay.
I need to buy, yeah, I need to buy the stack station.
Do I, can I afford it?
I don't even know if I can afford the stack station pin.
Okay.
100 geo?
Okay, nice.
Cocoon.
Oh, there it is.
I actually needed that.
Is there anything else here?
No, it's just markers.
Yeah, we don't need the hot spring or anything.
Alright.
We just gotta go down.
Finally, I missed the Crossroads Stag Station somewhere.
But, like, it didn't even show on the map.
Nevi!
Thank you for the raid!
I saw you also play Hollow Knight!
I play Hollow Knight, too!
The never-ending Hollow Knight raid.
What if I just raid another YouTuber that's also playing Hollow Knight?
We're all just gonna watch Hollow Knight for the rest of our lives.
Sorry, I'm in.
I'm playing Silk Star right now, guys.
Guys, I got early access to silk sawing.
Look at that.
Wait a second.
Yeah, guys.
I got early access.
My Jane silk sawing.
Okay, where the fuck is the stack station on this area?
Guys, okay, where's the stack station for this area?
Wait, no, no, spoilers!
What the fuck is this mod?
It's called Getting Silk Song Early Axes.
That's the mod.
Down?
Down, right?
Oh, it's...
Oh, I think I see it.
Yeah, Silk Song is apparently a game that's about...
Oh, that's the...
It's about her past.
That's why she's tied me.
Okay.
It is...
Okay, I haven't gotten this.
this way yet where's this way oh there it is insert goo it's over here let me in you know who i am i'm jean silk sign where the fuck am i oh my god this is the crystal area okay never mind i was not supposed to be here all right Yeah, this is the Crystal Mountains.
Damn, I'm trying to find the goddamn...
Okay, it's down, maybe?
Oh, wait, this is breakable.
Let me in.
That's right, I'm here for my government's check.
Nice.
Another one in foster care.
My foster care.
Alright, this way.
Oh, hey, is this guy?
I'm gonna kill you just for the sake of it.
Just for the fun of it.
I don't even need to kill you.
Alright.
It was down?
God damn it, I'll never find Silk So, I mean, I'll never find the Stag.
It's down.
Hello, this room.
Oh, is it here?
Oh, it's here!
I found him.
I did it.
Wait, who the- Oh, it's this guy!
It's- It's mysterious, sexy Tumblr bug.
Hello?
Hello thing.
Use those old lines?
Pathetic.
A real warrior carries himself to combat.
He has no need for such convenience.
Alright.
God, so mysterious.
Now thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My dad is team cherry and sent Doki to early access.
He said he'll only fully release it if she gets a true ending.
song today for another 20 years.
That guy doesn't like public transport.
What's wrong with him?
Does he hate?
Does he hate children?
I'd like that.
I'd like him.
Oh, what the fuck?
He gave that sky a shield.
Oh my god.
My man.
He hates the people.
What's over here?
I've never been to this area.
What's that?
What is that side?
Oh!
The upper entrance will be better.
Okay, we'll get there.
Go ahead there.
Alright, it's this way.
We'll go back to the one we found earlier.
This one?
Was this the one?
Or the toll booth?
Okay.
yeah okay how strong are they oh I see they're that strong wait how the fuck do I steal their money then the key is only yeah I'm just LARPing guys it's just it's LARP I'm just role-playing as Jane Silk's on I'm
I'm actually, like, chaotic good.
No.
Lawful good.
I'm a lawful good person.
How do I get over there?
Oh, I hit the face only.
Oh, okay.
I see.
I can't smack his ass.
He didn't consent.
It's like no ass smack.
Oh, it's her!
Milo or something
Hello Are you seeing a...
Oh, it's not her!
It's not...
I'm sorry They all looked... They all looked the same I thought it was she...
It looked like her It's...
That was like, hey friend Hey friend!
Oh, there's a bench.
Where's my bed?
Oh, there it is.
Mommy, sleepy.
Gotta rest.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't believe her lies.
She wouldn't even love us if we were bugs.
Yeah, but you're not bugs.
Count your blessings.
Code name.
Welcome to tomato fire.
Welcome, welcome.
You should be happy, you're not disgusting bug.
Alright, we go here.
I already used the bench.
What the fuck does this?
Okay, oh yeah, it does.
Okay, I was gonna say, does it disappear?
That shit's OP.
Bugs aren't disgusting.
Are you an ant?
Are you?
Who paid you to say that in my chat?
Oh, hey, a net is...
Oh, it's blocked.
I gotta go this way.
What if they are?
This is not safe space for ants.
Okay.
There's some areas a little annoying.
but it's not as annoying as the worms.
We could be dragon blasts.
We could change for you.
Alright, I'll pay for the surgery.
Alright, we go this way.
Okay, this is definitely a boss fight.
Like, where am I?
Am I, like, in a cemetery?
How do I fuck that get into the cemetery?
Curse your dose you turn against the king.
How did I get here?
How was it in the mine?
I yearned for it.
Oh, I didn't have enough souls.
Oh.
Aliens?
Right after the beast's vessel.
The dream really is sleeping.
Monomon, the teacher, in her archive, surrounded by fog and mist.
Lorian, the watcher.
In his spy, I looked over the bug aliens.
Am I in Area 51?
Herod the beast in her den amidst a deep darkness beyond the kingdom.
Through her devotion, Hallnest lasts eternal.
Oh?
Dreamer locations added to the map.
Go no further, little shadow.
What compels its climb out of the dark?
what compels its return to the sacred kingdom.
A call from beyond the seals.
Buy the vessel or buy that captain life.
With the seals break, they cannot be undone.
But the vessel weakens.
That plague springs anew.
They must be undone.
Yet still our seals remain.
Our duty holds.
It must be cast away.
It shall be done.
What happened?
Oh my god, bug aliens!
Fade away, little shadow.
Fade away.
And let us sleep in peace.
Oh, it's just sleeping.
What a weird dream.
Wow.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Oh?
Hello?
Oh.
still dreaming.
Go, go, go.
Why is there a downside?
Okay.
Like, why is there, like, a random one that's down here?
Like, is there a secret?
I like that.
It's, like, tempting me to jump down.
I feel like if I do that, I'm going to lose all my progress.
The boy.
All right.
Get a right out go.
Yo.
Oh, it's a moth!
What a terrible fate they visited upon you.
To cast you away in the space between body and soul.
Will you accept your judgment and fade slowly away?
Or will you take the weapon before you and cut your way out of the sad, forgotten dream?
All right.
I want to say no to a free weapon.
in.
Yoink.
Free is free.
Taken the dream nail.
A charge and slash from the nail.
Cut through the veil between dream and waking.
Okay.
Ah!
You returned!
Welcome back to the waking world.
Those figures.
Those dreamers.
They reached out with what little power they still have And dragged you into the sitting place That talisman you now wield The dream now You can cut through the veil that separates The waking world from our dreams Even the dreamers themselves Can not hide from such a weapon Though I must admit That sacred blade has to hold over time Together perhaps we can restore its powers Only out to bring me Essence Essence fragments of life that dreams are made of collect it whenever you find it and bring it to me once we have enough we can work wonders together go out into the world wielder hunt down the essence that lingers there collect a hundred essence and return to me i'll teach you more what are you doing poking about a dusty old man like mine nothing i'm worth this hidden side believe me.
I keep hovering around the world with you and your dream now.
Other things will reveal itself.
What the fuck do I do with this?
Wait, what do I do with this, though?
How the fuck do I do with the dream now?
Oh!
Is it... Oh!
These trees!
Oh my god, I don't remember where any of these trees are.
Is it time?
Or are these timed?
Wait, there's one up top.
Oh, it's like, they're like dream catchers.
They're shaped like dream catchers, I just noticed.
No?
Okay, nice.
Oh, there's so many.
Oh, are these Essence?
Oh, they're Essence!
Holy shit, it's just nearly all Essence.
I just realized...
Oh, I don't have...
I don't have enough souls for that.
Okay, that should be the last one.
Yay!
I did it!
There is a stack station here.
So... Oh.
You were here?
Okay, I gotta buy it from him then.
All right, get over here.
Oh my god, I didn't have to pay for this one Where was, okay, I don't have a map Oh my god The government paid for this one finally So many great Were more fairs and old Siamese I've forgotten Somewhere along The line lies the stag nest The place where I was born And raised I thought its Location lost to my failing mind But now I can almost remember the path.
They keep open static station, infecting me through them.
First again, find that nest.
I would like that very much.
All right.
The resting ground.
All right, we got by the map.
We got by the map from his wife.
You're like, it can give you a chunk of salt.
You can do a lot of different things.
Like what?
Oh, oh yeah, I can like analyze him.
All right, I'll analyze them.
I'm gonna say.
Slash!
I tire so easily now, and my old legs seem to take more and more.
So, I'm lucky to grow old at all.
So many others have it.
Oh, no.
They got taken by the bug catchers.
They're all in the illegal beetle fight ring.
Oh, I'll slash this old man.
Splash!
Descend into that ruin.
Why?
Things are so much simpler here.
Heard the tales of the Kolar's lines.
A web of a tunnel is running all through the kingdom.
I'm quite content where I am.
Alright.
We gotta get the resting grounds.
Okay, is she gonna...
What is she gonna say about her husband?
Slash!
I'm glad I put my weapon down my weapon.
Quiet life with Courtney makes me a lot happier.
It would be nice to stretch my legs again, though.
Sometimes I'm scared.
I can't believe he would do such a thing to her.
Keeping her hold up in this shop.
I never do that to you, baby girl.
If you come with me, we can go adventuring everywhere.
Can't believe it.
She is a free thinker.
to be locked in that shop.
She's not actually happy.
She's coping, guys.
Do we not read the same...
Do we not read the same dialogue?
She's just coping.
All right, we got to this way.
No, she's coping, guys.
Okay, we gotta grab more souls so I can unlock that crypt.
Just think it was a super chat.
Thank you.
ma'am, I'll free you.
Wait, is it this again?
Am I going to be trapped in the dream world again?
For reading this?
No, okay.
I couldn't tell.
Alright.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh, that's a dream thing.
I recognize that.
Flash!
Oh, shit!
I'm sorry!
Did I wake you from your slumber?
Oh!
like okay I okay I was not expecting a fucking boss fight I was just trying to be like hey there buddy how the fuck was I supposed to know this was a boss fight I just wanted to talk okay Jesus Christ can I just talk oh my god that's four that's more than two guys four swords is more than two who would have thought wait okay does it know oh my gosh whoops jesus this is so scary Oh wait,
no, it's not.
Thanks for letting me like, I mean, I guess I'll take the free heal.
I'm not complaining.
Jesus Christ, how much HP do you have?
Nice.
Alright, hello.
I can see now, those who turn against the king are doomed.
their weapons.
Do not call me a traitor.
Simply call me a fool.
I know you want to flee.
Where you will go.
I will be watching.
Oh shit, I did it.
I just wanted to read his minds and then he attacked me.
It's fucked up.
Nice, I got essence though.
Curse your dose to turn against.
Oh, it's this thing.
Oh, man.
I used up my heels for that.
The soles for that.
It has to be, like, an area where I can gather some souls.
That's another...
Oh.
What?
Where does this go?
Oh, nowhere.
I can slot for some kind of pass.
Oh, I don't have it.
I don't have the pass.
Who's going to give me the pass?
hurts ghosts like a normal oh it was i was hurting him whoopsie i can't dive down because i don't have any solos with me
how do i get solos here upsies or how do i get upies i demand upies
is there any soul area here because that's the stag.
There's the tree.
There's a room to the red.
This one?
I can't open that.
Or I can't open that either.
This is the stag area.
Can I use the dream?
No.
Oh, talk to the seer?
Let me have a look at the dream now.
Hmm, already you collect 100 essence things come naturally to you don't they no wonder the dreamers try to bury you in that old dream perhaps you frightened them or perhaps being prisoners themselves they desire your company in any case you still have a long way to go take this old trinket as encouragement from me and return where you collected 200 essence oh nice priest uh after out real quick.
Another freestyle.
Alright.
I still need anything down here.
Oh, nice.
Okay, we need that.
I didn't see that.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now we can open the creepy old crypt.
Hoop.
Oh, shit.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, he's dead.
Guys, did I kill the...
Did I kill the injured and sick?
No.
Right?
Guys, you saw it.
It was self-defense.
You saw that.
It was self-defense, guys.
I didn't kill...
I didn't kill the injured or sick, guys.
I was simply defending myself.
Oh.
I was like, what's underneath me?
I was like thinking, is that?
What are they called?
Like, are they lepers?
I was like, oh my god, did I?
Oh no.
Oh, it's self-defense.
You came at me first.
What was that?
A soul eater.
What's a soul eater?
Forgotten.
to draw soul from still really increased amount of soul gain when striking an enemy with a nail.
Oh, wait, that's better than this.
Oh, but then I think, okay, but I don't have enough.
I can't do anything with it.
I don't have enough.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I got healed first.
Yeah, but I need like, I need slots for it.
I don't have enough slots.
Okay.
There must be something to my left then okay this is how you get out so i'm gonna go this way first
all right i know it seemed like i hit him first but like he looked at he he wanted to kill me you guys saw in his face right he looked at me funny and there was death in those eyes Jesus, I fucking knew it.
It was self-defense, guys.
He had intent.
Exactly.
He had intent, guys.
Now where am I?
Wait, what?
Where is this place?
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Yeah, those were killer eyes.
I can go down.
Oh!
What?
Where is this place?
I killed the rich bugs though.
Eat the rich.
Alright, let's go back up.
Uh, uh...
Guess I'll go this way?
You're more breakable stuff.
Oh, here.
I was like, there has to be one more breakable thing.
I hear it.
So many secrets in here.
Hello.
Knock, knock.
Scrape robber here.
I come from the UK.
Nice.
We're here for them.
Our museums.
There's more to the left.
Yeah?
I don't think so.
Alright.
Where else do we go?
I feel like if I take the...
What?
Yeah, I got all the I got all the walls here.
Unless there's a... Okay, where does this go?
Oh, it goes back to the crib.
Okay, there was a breakable floor down here.
With the Oh, it wasn't.
It was with the ghost I killed.
It's like right here.
God damn it.
I didn't realize I ran out of slows.
Alright, never mind.
Guess we'll never find out.
We'll never find out.
We'll go back into the crypt key.
Alright.
Go to the left area.
Wee!
To the left, right?
I feel like to go back to, like...
Oh my god, what?
What?
I think I might die.
Okay, wait.
I gotta kill the rich real quick.
Give me a sec.
Wait, where are they?
Did I kill all of them?
Oh, that's awkward.
Okay, this guy.
All right, I guess not.
All right, there we go.
Oh, shit!
They had a bodyguard!
Where did the bodyguard come from?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm here.
Oh, my God.
The bodyguard came out.
me the rich fought back how was I supposed to know he had a bodyguard where did he come from
can't believe it they had security who would have thought goddamn rich has security they have money to buy a pot how am I supposed to eat the rich if they are if they are guarding them
What do I want to have?
What do I want me to do?
Starve?
Alright, where the fuck is my soul?
Get over here.
Where the fuck is my flying soul?
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
That's fine.
A fucking corpse.
I would accidentally get into a trap room.
They baited me with all these wealthy bugs.
It was just so tempting.
They're like, oh, she would never, she could never resist.
Killing all the rich.
She couldn't resist, and they were right.
They were fucking right.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Nice.
How the fuck are you still alive?
As greedy as they are.
Oh nice.
I mean, I needed this anyway.
Whoa!
We still songs out?
Yeah!
I got early access.
And nice.
And now we can go back down.
Okay, and I actually need that for HP.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah!
People...
Why?
You think people would just lie on the internet like that?
That's fucked up.
Oh my god, I really...
Dude, I want to deal with these guys.
Okay.
I don't know what this opens, but...
You go up.
Oh, it's back here.
Oh.
Man, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Oh, nice.
Secret.
Oh, it was just morsels.
Okay.
Go left.
What's this?
Oh, is this a hot springs?
Oh, it's just a lake.
I swim, swim, swim.
Swim, swim, swim.
I keep swimming.
swimming.
I'm still swimming.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be swimming.
Just keep swimming.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, what a calm place.
These actions I want.
Vicious and deadly battle.
This sinner, I think, is a boar.
Oh.
It's like me.
I hate nature.
Okay.
Wait, is that it?
Is that it?
Baby koala.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki will never lie to attack bugs unjustly.
Exactly.
Why would I ever do that?
It's pretty fucked up.
I can...
Wait, what?
What did I unlock?
Was that orb?
Oh, I can carry more...
Oh, it lets me carry more souls.
Hello?
Oh, you surprised.
me hello hello come in sweetling come in and make yourself at home i'm salubra and this is my cozy little charm store does the town folk out there tell you to come and visit me yes this is a lovely little village isn't it warm and intimate and full of life what are you talking about oh yes charms i can see you start your own collection very nice i'll show you some of my own and you can take one home with you if you like for free oh no not for free have you drunk that bright liquid life blood it's a bit of a taboo but makes you feel the charm seems like blood and will certainly improve your constitution what the fuck is life blood mr broken bond thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um today is now at 12 a.m you see march my 29th birthday Here is another you,
all dragons and hues.
Thanks for being so amazing and funny.
Thank you, Mr. Broken Pond.
We're the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Broken Pond.
Yeah, happy birthday.
We have a great birthday, lady.
Oh, Shaman Stone is the best one.
Oh, it'll make my spell stronger.
Yeah, I might as well buy that.
I just need, like, charm notch.
Oh, nice.
oh this is just oh cool okay i just have to buy this okay never mind i can't afford it okay yeah i just need to spend my money on that okay well at least i can
is there anything that's one well i guess guys don't judge guys don't guys this i i have to wear it Because it's...
It does damage.
Guys, I am just...
It's just...
Guys, it's just aura.
Okay?
Nothing else.
It's just aura.
Guys, it's just...
I'm not stinky.
It's just aura.
Okay, you don't understand.
It's...
Does this actually damage people?
Uh-oh, stinky.
Oh, it does?
Okay, nice.
because they're like amazed by my aura okay that's why they get damage wait where do we go do we go oh I guess we go oh we go back to crystal peak okay all right we'll go back to crystal peak yeah I think I can all do it this way congrats on becoming a reddit mod and gaining aura no they give us a super chat thank you thank you they're just so impressed with like my aura that they get hit by like emotional damage they're just like oh my god i wish i could be just like her and it's yellow because um i'm yellow that's why it's colored yellow
yeah we gotta get rid of these guys yeah the biological warfare the biological part It's just my existence.
It's just, uh, oh, wait.
You need that.
Ow.
Is that speedrun?
Speedrun!
Okay, this way.
Oh my god, I hate these guys.
These guys are so annoying.
Whoever gave these guys shields.
Okay, we go this way.
And then...
And it's this way.
I'll do the crystal thing all over again.
Did I even find a map?
I can't even find a map for it, too.
So it's like, I don't know where to go.
Did I?
I don't remember.
Nope, I didn't find no signal.
Nope.
Nope, never mind.
I didn't find a map.
I never got a signal.
What's this?
Oh, it's just money.
I didn't the only boss that I like Struggled Was the Mantis one But that was just me like getting rage baited I need all the other bosses I first tried
Okay Is there Oh there was this stuff
I got a twin mushroom I don't even remember who that fucking boss was
I don't think that was a boss I was just like they were just there it would be fucking annoying oh my god guys look I got another egg how much many more eggs do I need
yeah I got consumed by anger
yeah I either die from like the dumbest enemies or like platforming I don't even remember like how where to go I don't remember it.
Okay, maybe here.
Okay.
Yay!
Maybe here?
Okay, I thought there was something here.
I didn't even see that Cornelius.
He hasn't left me, um, like, a trail.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no.
Not these.
I'm just gonna go this way.
Fuck that shit.
Government check right there.
Have to do it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, Mark.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
Oh, I don't even have charge.
I swear to God.
If it makes me do the whole thing all over again, I swear to God.
Okay, nice.
Government check.
Done.
Another caterpillar in my foster care.
What the fuck is that?
Can I kill it?
Oh, I can't.
Okay, that's good to know.
Okay, I can't kill these.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
Alright.
Oh, they don't even give me that money.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I see the paper trip.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alright.
He's leaving the breadcrumbs.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, I'm so overwhelmed.
There's so many lies.
Oh, there he is.
Come to scare the monsters.
I heard the telly of someone waiting out there too far for me, though.
And I'm not really one for heights.
Alright, nice.
Finally got the map.
Fucking finally.
How do I get up there?
Because I don't have the item yet.
Um...
I don't think I'm allowed to go there.
Yeah, I'm not allowed to go there.
I guess I go up?
Am I gonna get... Yes.
Okay.
I need to grab those souls.
I really...
Oh, fuck!
I hate these crystals with bugs.
okay nice there's a bench here yeah my gamer aura what the fuck hello oh okay sorry i'm sorry for wiki i'm sorry oh shit i'm dumb i'm fucking over first try oh my god i'm sorry i didn't know you
No!
He was just sitting on the...
I'm all the way here!
Okay.
If I take this, do I get the...
I mean, it's fine.
It's just double damage, right?
It should be fine.
It's so far!
It's so far.
Oh my god.
It's not fine.
Wait, was it the wrong charm?
Oh my god, it was the wrong charm.
Oh well.
All right, we'll go back.
Wrong charm.
I can't believe it in my first tribe boss run.
I just, it was just so much.
Oh, you know, that's not what we want.
We wanted, what was it called?
Traman stole this one, right?
Was it that?
Oh, so sad.
You know, they give us a super chat.
thank you thank you i was just not expecting a boss fight i was not expecting it so i my i wasn't locked in i was just trying to wake him up he was gonna miss a stop i was like sir you're gonna miss your bus stop sir i was just trying to be a good good upstanding citizen
mean oh my god i gotta fucking remember how to get there again it's so up i was waking him up he's gonna miss his bus stop how was that mean i
was just trying to be an upstanding citizen to where i don't fucking know he's the one that was at the bus stop Killed me before I could ask!
Oh my god, I have to do this bullshit again.
Oh my god, I have to do this stupid thing again.
I'm gonna smack your ass.
Smack that bump on an ass, smack that.
Wait, is it this way?
Okay, it is.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, he's only three hits, so I don't have to worry that much.
Oh, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, I can't get down.
Okay, now that I know he doesn't like it when people wake him up, I'm gonna do it again.
Oh, my god, I hate this area so much.
I'm gonna do this part again, though.
I'm sad to do this part again.
Okay.
oh my god okay no all right and it's up here all right now I know now I know he doesn't like it so I will do it again all right all
right here we go okay I know now I know now I know that he doesn't like it now oh fuck did I hit no I can't okay okay I wasn't sure if I can hit okay so I have to just jump behind him okay that's fine are you serious oh my god oh my god okay okay now I know Okay.
Okay, now I know that I'm...
Oh, he wasn't even a boss.
He was just a normal guy.
Oh,
it's fine.
That's why I didn't die.
I'm okay.
What's this?
Thank God he was just a normal guy.
okay so i have to go down here okay so i have to open that passageway too he's a mini boss yeah thank god i don't worry too much
why am i healing i have a bench because i'm scared
i'm scared oh my god
He's just cranky.
You won't give up.
Thank you for the super chat, Zero.
Thank you.
Oh, this area is fucking sucks.
Okay, map says this way.
Every new area sucks more and more.
Oh, hey, Coral.
I have quite a view, no?
I'm not surprised you survived the trek through these shimmering caverns.
a strength about you.
I suspect it would be quite intimidating if not for your small stature.
Thanks.
He called me a short.
Not even a short king.
That's so fucking rude.
I'll have you know.
I am almost five feet.
Wait, that's really tall for a buck.
I'm almost five inches.
I'll have you know.
I just haven't hit purity yet, okay?
God, so fucking rude.
All right.
Wait, there's something over here.
And that's money!
Why do I can...
Oh, I'm just thinking, can I like...
Just smack that.
Bumpa da da da.
Smack that.
All right, nice.
Oh, I got another journal.
What's below me, though?
Oh, it's another...
Another rancid egg.
That I can't even get.
it.
Is there anything here?
What's the point of being here?
Hello?
It's just going down and down and what?
What is this place?
Oh, a shortcut.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
It's So pretty, though.
I will admit.
This is really pretty.
Alright, and then Apako.
Oh, shit!
Okay, I need a dash for that.
I wasn't paying attention.
Alright.
I need to remember to just dash instead of jump.
Okay, shortcut.
Grab some souls.
Souls of the children.
Sustained my lifestyle.
Oh, my God.
What am I looking at?
What am I fucking looking at now?
Yeah.
Part four.
Part no!
No!
Oh, this is not fair.
This is not fair.
Oh, thank god there's more souls.
Yeah, this guy, that was a little messy.
Get down, I go.
Whoa!
so fast.
I didn't like it.
Can't do that way.
So I guess I go this way?
Hello?
It's a boy.
Oh, shit.
Hi.
Oh, crystal hard.
Hood LT.
Wild on the ground.
Click.
Townsend.
Release.
The blast forward.
LT.
That's it.
Wee!
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, I got dashed.
I got super dash.
Wee!
Yay!
Oh, shit.
I can't stop.
Alright, now I can.
Oh, is that it?
Is that all I need to get?
There has to be a boss fight here.
Alright?
Wait, where am I?
I feel like I'm...
Oh, I missed a grub?
There's a grub.
Oh, I hear it.
Oh, I hear him.
Okay, but how do you get that?
He's so far up.
Oh, here?
Oh!
Oh, okay, wait.
I get it.
How do I do the super charge?
Oh, I get there.
Yeah, but we can't do the dash.
Why wouldn't it let me do the dash on the wall?
What?
I'm trying to, but...
When I'm sliding, it won't let me.
Wait, how did I do that?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
i had like okay it's because i was pushing another button no i was pushing another button and that's why i was like sliding like i have to like not push anything with lt i get it now yeah so confused i was like excuse me sir i am trying to i am trying the super dash sir that
was useless i didn't need Where else can I go?
Can I go up here now?
Wow.
Oh, yeah, I can.
Nice.
Yay, shortcut.
Okay.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
I haven't eaten yet in four hours.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back, everybody.
Next scene you're in me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Wake up.
Wake up, Samurai.
It's time.
What the fuck do I go next?
Wake up, Samurai.
We gotta figure this out together.
Okay.
Maybe up?
I guess I have to go up.
There's stuff up there.
Ah, shit.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's so many things!
Okay, it's this way.
Okay.
Up.
Okay, there's stuff upstairs that I haven't gone.
And it's like...
Far...
Okay, it's far up.
Hey?
I'm trying to read the map right now.
Guys, I might be really bad at reading this map.
That's just the maybe.
Can't go up.
So I go this way?
Yeah.
Yeah, but there's stuff on the right side I haven't gone yet.
Like here.
Right here.
Alright, never mind.
I guess I can't go there.
Never mind.
We'll go back to that one area.
We go down.
Yeah, we go down with the crystal thing.
Okay, so then they play Cyberpunk 2777 in the near future.
Isn't that game like super long?
I don't know.
I know like that game is incredibly long.
and it has like, uh, because it's basically like, uh, what's it called?
Oh my god, I'm hitting everything.
It's basically future.
GTA, but in the future, it's a very big open world, yeah.
But then you have a super chat, oh, and then you thank you.
Also think of a super chat Power Pro and Marie.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Okay, here.
Let me do this.
Oh my god, I'm like, uh, I'm like Goku.
And flying.
That's super saiyan mode.
Oh, nice.
Oops.
We don't do that again.
Oh, my God.
We do that again.
Wait, secret below.
There's a secret room exactly below.
Where is it?
Where's the secret room?
Huh?
Oh, not yet.
Okay.
Okay, I see.
I know your name now, S-Ran.
That took you, right?
Now I know you're one of those one guys.
My head.
Yeah, that's right.
Your head.
You're on very thin.
That is down.
Oh, shit.
Oops.
Yeah.
wait am i gonna hit that no we're fine oh i see it is that the secret room over there wait i'll turn this on first i see it i see it there you go where is this this is area
oh i hear like i hear my government check nearby am i sipping there he is that's right oh it's over there oh there's more what the fuck where did this guy come what oh it was a fake oh shit okay it was a fake yeah i was like what the fuck was that okay now he's a real one bro you could have bro what the fuck we could I don't got a...
I would have been such a good parent for you.
Look how I went to a foster care.
Yeah, that's a mimic.
I didn't even notice it.
I was just like, what the fuck?
Why are he angry?
Oh, shit!
Fall damage isn't real.
It's okay.
Fall damage isn't real in this game.
Another real thing, a weapon?
I suppose you'll be loving me and the corpse in your wake.
If you won't spare thought for then, at least consider all the extra work you've forced upon those in my profession.
Alright, time to make him mad.
Inky time!
Oh shit, never mind, I just absorbed him.
Never mind, you'll never find peace.
Yeah.
What?
Oh.
Oh, it was a cemetery.
Oh!
Oh, shit, my elevator!
Wait, that's my ride!
Oh, it comes back down.
Okay, nice.
Toki, why?
The murderer!
I thought he would fight!
How was I supposed to know he doesn't fight back?
Everybody else fought back
Altimore welcome to a tomato farm welcome welcome not all ghosts fight How is I supposed to know it's okay.
He's one inside.
He's inside me now.
It's okay.
He's one with me
Yes, my the one guy I fought was all the data I needed to know that all ghosts were bad What's that unprovoked, by the way?
Why, that's the key to my storeroom.
I thought I lost it for good.
Did you find it in those old mines, perhaps?
They're curious.
I have no idea how it ended up in such a remote place.
Very honest with you, they returned to me.
Yes, very kind.
And now that I couldn't open up my old storeroom, I can sell you some of the rare stock that's been gathering dust there.
These items may be a little worn, but they still retain their full market value.
Very precious stuff.
Take a look.
All right, elegant key.
I mean, that seems good.
I feel like I should buy the key, right?
Yeah, an elegant key for an elegant lock.
Yeah, the key seems like worth it.
All right.
We just need to save up.
Yeah, we got to save up for the charm stuff.
How was I supposed to know that he doesn't...
Leave and re-enter the room?
Okay.
I don't have enough money for the charm slot yet.
Why do I have to re-enter the shop?
He seems fine.
I don't know that.
Some of the older people have the experience.
I thought he was one of those experienced fighters.
I was going to fuck me up.
It was self-defense.
That old man had a gun.
He had a gun, guys.
I know you didn't see it, I saw it.
Alright, let's see.
Where was it?
I saw it.
Check the body of me.
Rewind the body.
Rewind the cameras.
And he had a gun.
It was tucked away.
Underneath his shell.
You guys didn't see it.
But I.
He had a ghost gun.
That was scarier.
I thought he would fight back.
We go to King Station or I guess it's King Station.
Yeah.
Where was it?
Where was the key area?
I don't really exactly remember.
Oh.
Does you guys remember?
I don't.
Oh.
Oh, I remember now.
Was it...
Is it...
This one?
Is this one, right?
Is that one?
That's okay, Joki.
I'm like the dragoons.
At least the ghosts ain't...
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I like how...
I saw you, Smite!
I saw you said no!
Everyone else said yes, but you!
thought i was gonna get another one god jokes on you i saw what you said what the fuck was this is this a church
all right oh it was a family oops a little oopsie daisy there
As if this is a church and then suddenly start stabbing.
You mod.
Oh, there was a secret room?
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Go back.
Alright, it's like here.
Oh, shit.
You fought back.
What are you doing?
Fighting back.
You know what happens when people fight back?
No, Doki.
What happens when people fight back?
people.
It's okay.
You don't want to know.
Don't worry about it.
What?
Nothing happens when they fight back.
Yeah.
Okay, there you go.
Where's the secret room?
Here?
What are you talking about?
There ain't no secret in this church.
Oh shit, what?
God, they were hiding it.
What what is that?
I don't even know what to say this is.
What the fuck were they hiding?
What was
that?
He's a rich man.
They were hiding a rich man
He's glow.
It's the rich grandpa.
Oh, so I asked why I did do a home in
I'm like, what even are you?
Wee.
Literally, I broke into his panic room.
I was like, surprise.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I can read.
Oh, yeah, I can read his journal.
You're right.
Wondering husk.
Where is he?
I want to read his little journal.
That's me.
That's the shade.
Does he even have...
Wait, he doesn't even have a journal.
He's not even that important.
Okay, husk dania.
Oh, there he is.
Gorgeous husk.
Corpulent husk, encrusted with shiny metal, retains the instinct to hordgia.
There's a beauty in many things.
Oh, yeah.
There he is.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Wait, is there more?
Is there more to him?
Wait, what are these?
Oh, yeah, they're former members of high society.
Yeah, I knew it.
I gotta say.
Just look at Doki, nailing all the rich both in their dreams and reality.
That's right.
I ended the bloodline.
I always say you gotta end the bloodline.
Okay, how do I get there?
Up!
Can I still go up?
I can't tell.
Yeah, I can.
Up.
Am I fully up now?
Okay, I am.
Okay.
I gotta figure out how to get out of here.
Your life doesn't matter.
I killed an old man.
Where is it?
Where's the other section I had to go?
Yeah?
Wait, no.
Oh no, I forgot.
I forgot.
Oh, it's here.
The escalator's right here.
Wait, how the fuck do I get there?
Oh my god, I actually forgot how to do this.
Let's let...
Because I can't go up from here.
Oh my god.
I'm lost.
Is it here?
Maybe it's here.
No.
How the fuck?
How do I get there?
Down to the right then.
Oh, it's up here.
JK, I figured it out.
All by myself.
No help whatsoever.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Give me my house.
Elevator up.
Yeah, it's still time.
Oh my god, I said up.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, this way.
And then...
Oh my god, shit.
Okay, this way.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, no.
It is this way.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
I was like telling him, I was like, wait, is this?
this way?
I made a shortcut here.
Now it's this way.
Okay, now we got it.
We did it.
We figured it out.
It took me forever, but we figured it out.
Yes, an elegant key for an elegant door.
Yeah, broke into Grandpa's panic room.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, my God, it's this guy again.
again.
Oh my god, I hate this guy.
I hate this guy so much.
I forgot how much I hate him.
Oh my god.
I think I might actually die to this guy, though.
I forgot how to fight him.
Oh my god, I actually forgot how to fight this guy.
No!
Ah!
I forgot!
Oh!
Shit, where am I?
Okay.
All right, I guess where's this fucking bus stop again?
Oh my God.
I'm all the way here.
I forgot to take that bench.
How do I get back?
Okay, it's this way.
Streamer, what?
I was gonna charge up.
I forgot about the bench, guys.
I didn't bench.
I didn't think it'd be a boss fight!
Oh my god, I gotta do this again.
I didn't think it was a boss fight.
I thought it was just chilling with the homies.
Oh my god.
It's so far.
Because I didn't know.
I wasn't ready.
Okay, let's heal in this bench first before I do anything.
So at least that kills half the time.
I wasn't locked in.
All of crap.
Don't worry.
We'll get Grandpa's money back.
Sack the storerooms for a quicker travel.
Where's the storerooms?
I don't even remember.
I miss sword.
Where the fuck is the storeroom?
That's faster?
Where is this?
How is that?
Oh, I guess it is faster.
This is faster.
I'm gonna rest here.
Keyframe, we hitting 60 hours for sure.
Chats, no.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know.
Alright.
And then we go right.
All the way right.
We...
Oh wait, I have a tree here.
Ow.
Okay, that was...
Not there.
I remember there was a tree here.
Here?
Oh, there it is.
That's where I can bait it.
Alright.
Tree!
Oh my god, it's so far.
Wait, do I have to hit the tree again?
To like, um...
If I don't get all of the essence uh, from that tree, And I just leave it?
Do I have to get it again?
I'm curious.
Like, do I have to hit the tree?
Oh my god, get me out of here.
Yes, yes, but not all of it?
Okay.
Just whichever one I didn't do.
Whichever one I just didn't receive.
Where am I?
I'm like, where am I flying to?
Eh, fuck it.
I don't really care that much.
I'm just gonna leave.
Goodbye.
Okay, then I just go straight to the right.
Don't worry, Goku's coming over.
Damn it.
What the fuck?
I popped and then the other guy was like, no!
Bad!
Alright.
Okay, now I'll lock in, I think.
I don't know.
Most likely not.
My god!
Oh my god!
I'm not locking in.
I literally forgot how to fight this guy.
I'm just gonna say it.
I don't remember how to fight him.
Please!
I hate him.
I forgot to sit on the bench!
I forgot to sit on the other bench.
I have to go all the way there.
I just realized there was another bench that I didn't sit at.
Oh my god.
I was not struggling in any other bosses, but yet I struggle with- I hate magic users.
I hate mages.
I hate them so much.
I hate magic users.
Okay.
There you go.
I sat.
Okay, let's see if I can get- getting wrecked by a nerd.
to check if there's like any actual souls I can borrow it's stupid ass nerd
like what okay that's full are you serious are you serious oh my god I hate I hate the mini guys too the mini guys is like fucking with me really hard like
these guys these guys are fucking with me Oh my god!
Oh my god, I shut the focus.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, get your ass out of here.
Get your fucking ass out of here, you fucking nerd.
You don't deserve to be here.
Leave!
Your kindness and welcome here.
What's this?
A figure connected to...
To a device.
Okay, um, let me open this first before I do it.
All right, yes.
Hello?
Don't be toxic.
Just take the W.
It's not the same.
Tap to the spell consumes the same amount.
What?
Oh, Shadesa.
Is that better?
Stupid nerd.
Nerds aren't welcome here.
This is not a safe space for this nerd.
This exact nerd, though.
Only this particular nerd.
Alright.
Oh, I upgraded Fireball.
Fireball.
Okay, where do I go now?
No, it doesn't count.
I'm different.
Oh, it's double the damage?
Nice.
That's Ray.
nerds aren't safe here take you to the nearest toilet I'm gonna give you a goddamn swirly okay where do we go next guys
ancient basin okay I have we can get there would you love us if we were nerds where's ancient basin it's all the way down there okay I went down for no reason.
Is he gonna station closer?
Yeah, it is.
Uh, Unity, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good morning from Germany!
Good morning!
Good morning, Morgan.
Oh, what about this guy?
Alright.
I needed her soul anyway.
All right, take me to the king's station.
Ring ring.
All right, this way we go.
Oh, shit.
Let me sit on the bench just in case.
After everything we've been through, I'm just gonna make sure we have a bench.
Okay.
Not worth killing these guys.
These guys are like...
Like, these guys barely give me any money.
money.
Oh, whoops.
Uh, okay, ancient basin is right here.
Wee, oops, wee.
Wee, wee.
Ow.
Okay, that's fine.
Wee.
Oh, shit.
All right, nice.
We made it.
All right.
Here we go, here.
I don't remember.
Oh, it's this way.
Oh, it's the creepy bugs.
These guys.
Oh my god, fuck off.
Okay.
Got a heal real quick.
I killed all your friends and your sister.
Still coming over here?
And then we drop from here.
Wee!
Oh.
Alright, now we're in the ancient Basin or whatever.
Ancient Basin.
It's this way, right?
No, this wasn't it.
Where the fuck was it?
Guys, which way do we go?
Oh!
Wrong way.
I remember.
It's a bench from down there.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay, we gotta go down.
Okay, and then...
This way.
Down, down we go.
And then...
And then we do our dash.
Alright, nice.
That's a point.
oh shit money this is very important all right but we can't forget the oh oops speedrun we can't forget the money oh ow okay where the fuck am i
What?
What is that?
Why did y'all run away?
I'm not a bad person.
I'm not awful good.
Why did they run away?
Hello?
What's that?
Oh shit, what the fuck is that?
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, I just blasted.
It was too far away.
Too much work to get close to that.
Yeah, why would they run away?
Have they not heard about all the cool things I've did for society?
For bug society?
I don't know.
I'm just gonna leave.
Like, he just doesn't stop.
my god these guys fucking oh my god these guys fucking suck i'm just gonna oh my god okay this is bad this is actually very bad will he stop does he get tired sir can you
do not get tired sir please
Oh, fuck, okay.
Oh my god, I'm going this way.
Oh.
Simple key.
Let's...
Whoa.
Okay, that's good.
I got one.
Slow and steady.
I'll take those.
I got another one.
I hit a run.
Don't worry, I can grab him.
I can grab another hit.
There we go.
Baby steps.
Oh, fuck.
I got that greedy.
It got delayed.
That shit was delayed.
There we go.
Nice.
We're okay.
Are you serious?
That was supposed to be a pogo.
I don't know why I didn't pogo there.
Not as bad.
Okay, now I should be able to abuse magic here.
Oh my god, I hate this guy.
Okay.
Got the strong fiber.
Alright.
Okay, we did it.
Okay, I can be full HP too.
Alright, I think I figured out this pattern.
I figured out this pattern.
So it should be, like, easier.
Oh my god, GoSchool.
Okay, but where's over?
What's over here?
Okay, nothing.
Now there's GoSchool?
What did I do to you?
It's not my fault your children were just running in the open.
It's like they were begging to get...
Snashed.
You get shanked.
Right.
Why would they run in front of a stranger with a knife?
Huh?
That's their fault.
Okay, what's over here?
Jesus, toky.
What?
What did I do?
I'm just protecting us from all the other ghosts.
From the go school.
What's that?
Hello?
Am I supposed to...
Oh, shit.
Wait, what the hell?
Wait, no, no.
Stop, children.
Stop.
It was just a joke.
Children.
Stop.
Get out.
Oh, no.
I swear it was a joke.
Oh, my God.
Oh, they're fighting back.
The goo, I repeat, the goo is fighting back.
Oh my god, I can't even hit him.
I can't even hit him.
He's so fast.
Like, I don't know his patterns.
Holy shit.
I don't understand.
I actually don't understand.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can't.
fucking hit shit no
okay I actually walked into that I actually walked into that oh it's all goo it's just all goo I'm just gonna no okay that's not fair that's what's actually that was illegal no no no oh god oh god oh god not Toho anything Patojo.
Please let me go.
Please let me heal.
Let me heal.
Oh, I did it.
First try.
Let's go.
Oh, first try.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
That was so stressful.
I felt like I could never heal.
Yeah, first try.
Let's go.
Another first try.
I swear, I died to like mini bosses and not like actual bosses.
Oh, I can dream now that Whoops Well, I cannot Cat anymore No
Well, will he still be there, guys?
Will he still be there?
Wait, okay, okay
Alright, okay, he'll still be there Okay, cool Hey, cool.
Whoops.
Well, a corpse doesn't move.
I don't know.
I thought maybe, like, the ghoul would take him or some shit.
The ghoul would fucking transport him.
Or is this double jump?
Monarch wings.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
I get it.
Oh, wait.
I can get it.
I can go back now.
Okay, well, I'll go back.
and sordid him.
Okay, now I can.
Yay!
Double jump.
Are you still there?
Dream time!
Wait, where am I?
Wait a minute.
Hello?
Wait.
Where am I?
Where Where did I go?
Why am I here?
Hello?
How did I get here?
I don't like this area.
Why am I here?
Oh my god, I just killed you!
This is not fair.
You were supposed to be dead!
Oh my god!
Excuse me, why are you still here?
Oh my god, I'm getting hit by everything.
Oh my god.
I was not supposed to be here.
Oh my god, I was going to die anyway.
Yeah, we're not first trying this.
We're not first trying this.
Okay, I think I can kill him though.
We'll dream him again.
I think we can kill him.
Well, I got greedy.
I was like, I can just fall down.
I keep my stuff.
Oh, wait.
I keep everything.
That's nice.
Okay.
I keep everything.
I didn't know that.
Oh, what the...
Okay, I need to, like, know the range.
Oh, my God.
my god he's so fast actually oh my wait actually he he's so fast i'm not used to how fast he is oh my god he's actually so much faster wow
yeah he is a lot faster but i think i think i can beat him
okay we gotta lock in though if i'm gonna try this
I'll try to lock in This way Alright I think I can I just didn't make sure you remember he's a lot faster Than before Yeah like this Oh my god Oh my god That's crazy Holy shit Holy shit Holy shit
Oh my god, it- Oh!
No!
Okay.
Okay, we can do this.
He's incredibly fast.
No, I'm- I can do this.
I can do this.
I think I can.
I'm a gamer.
I know he definitely It definitely seems really difficult.
It's like, because for me, I'm not used to, like, how fast he is.
Like, I never remember, like, his movesets, too.
Like, because, like, I was playing his other movesets, so...
Because of that, I'm not used to, like, how much faster he is now.
These blobs are very annoying, too.
Oh my god.
These blobs are very annoying.
Oh, fuck.
I got the first stagger.
How many staggers does he have?
How many staggers does this guy have?
Three staggers?
Okay.
I'm just trying to speedrun going down.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, I just want to know how many staggers So I got to the first one, so that's already pretty good.
When he does that, it's so annoying, actually.
Like, because he lands straight on me, too.
Which is very annoying.
Jesus Christ.
I don't even think I can get a heal.
Yeah, I definitely can't get a heal for this.
I can't heal for this, yeah.
And see that?
And you can give you an extra edge to beat him.
Neri, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can get through.
the left side
the plunge gives you an invincibility frame I'm not really good with the plunge I'm not good at the plunge spell so like I rather just like yeah
yeah this one okay I just gotta be patient
Oh my god So fast
Land on the goo Oh my god The stupid fucking ghost The ghost is actually fucking me over The ghost fucked me over Holy shit The ghost is his little goddamn stupid ghost buddies but i'm getting it that was so cheap yeah if the ghost didn't fuck me over whoops goodbye and then i awakened from my dream okay
whoops i got a little cocky there with that
Whoa!
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
The goddamn stupid not back!
Okay.
I'm actually so locked in right now.
Oh my god, that was close.
Stupid!
Fucking...
Okay.
Nice.
I got fucked over.
I got fucked over so bad.
Oh my god, I got fucked over so bad.
Oh, I just got RNGed.
Yeah, I got RNGed so hard there.
I got RNGed really badly with that.
Whoops.
Aw, man.
Accident lost a lot of heals for the HP for that.
Yeah.
Oh.
I know his patterns, though.
Okay, I set that in.
I jinxed myself.
Oh, this is not the run.
This is not the run.
I jinxed myself.
I jinxed myself with that.
All right, let's just restart.
I'm going to restart this run.
I was like, I know his pattern, though.
Gets hit by all his attacks.
Never mind.
All right.
Yeah.
all right
all right i'm gonna hard focus chat i really need to focus this one this one is actually like really difficult so that i can't fuck around like my other my like my other boss runs
oh my god are you serious that's unlucky that's unlucky that's so unlucky okay okay like legitimately is literally the ghost that's fucking with me the most i think if it because i have to like i have to deal with the ghost oh the ghost is like so annoying because when i deal with the ghost he comes down i think i got two staggers there
i mean i created two well goodbye i wake up I wake up now What a dream Damn guys Got the wildest dream guys
Okay here you go What a destroyed dream Is it worth it though?
Whoops Sorry I looked at chat God sometimes I just okay oh okay I'm just gonna wait for the ghost to come to me
yeah no I didn't mean a dash I did not mean a dash there that was an accident
okay no okay
Yeah, one HP.
At least one HP.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
Ah!
You have the dream orange-blue remits constantly fly at you.
I figured out his fight mechanic, like his mechanics, though.
Yeah, I'm gonna try- I'm trying not to jump at the ghost, but- Oh my gosh, whoops.
I was impatient for that.
I'm trying not to jump at the ghost, but it's just...
It's just calling for me, you know?
He's rage-baiting me.
He knows.
Are you- he just jumped straight up in the air?
Oh my god, he definitely knows.
He is rage-baiting me.
The fact that he, like, jumped in, like, I don't know if you saw what I saw.
He literally just jumped in the center.
Like that, like, oh my god.
me up.
Are you serious?
There's two!
I think the other thing that tilts me is like
when like they spawn, literally whenever I got the stagger, they spawn.
And that like took me a lot.
Oh, I didn't get a chance to heal.
I didn't get a chance.
Oh.
I got this.
He jumped straight down, that psyched me up.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
It's hard to resist the orange font, the ghost.
Thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I will fucking beat this boss.
I'm determined.
I'm so determined.
I think, like, I've got him, like, no, several times already.
I remember, like...
Oh, my God.
Why would you jump so fucking far?
oh my god okay this is not the run this is definitely not the run
oh my god i don't have like anything this is definitely not the run though yeah this is not the run i won't boom
yeah i will kill you
Thing is, I want to save for a heal, but I don't know when I need the heal.
That's the thing.
His dash fucked me up.
Can I run?
Yes, I can.
Oh my god, I got one.
I got one healed.
Oh my god!
it oh
the ghost the ghost blocked me the ghost blocked me god damn it it's like rng too of like wherever the ghost spawns if the ghost spawns somewhere fucking bullshit i get fucked over oh fuck i always forget this is
Yeah.
I don't know.
All right.
I'm going in with one less HP.
Okay, I'm locking in.
I'm not going to talk much.
I have to lock in, for real.
Are you serious?
No!
I thought it was a dash.
No, of course I...
Of course.
Ah, the orb.
The orb.
He's the hardest boss.
If I beat him, all the other bosses are going to be super easy.
Okay, this time we're lucky.
I'm not going to talk much.
I have to focus for this.
It's actually, like, like the boss you have.
I have to focus on.
Oh, my God.
I got fucked over by timing.
He spawned in front of me!
Oh.
That...
Oh, my God.
The ghost spawned in front of me.
The ghost spawned in front of me when I was dodging.
Like...
That's actually so bullshit!
If he didn't spot in front of me, I could have been...
I got the timing.
Yeah.
I got... I literally got the timing if he didn't spot in front of me.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Mmm!
Okay.
That's a...
Oh my god, a stupid ghost.
Are you serious?!
Oh my
god, that's bullshit.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm getting it though.
I'm getting- I could have healed, but I got greedy.
Like, it's because all the ghosts kept spawning around me.
So, like, I got too scared to heal.
I got way too scared to heal.
There's just so many ghosts around me.
There were so many ghosts around me.
So, like, I just didn't know when to heal.
When would be the right time.
Sometimes when he does that, like, talks with me.
Oh, my God.
He should not have got that range.
so bullshit sometimes.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Are you serious?
That hits me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Got the parry, though.
At least.
Oh!
Oh my god, you stupid ghost!
Oh my god, the stupid...
All the ghosts kept respawning in front of me!
Oh!
I'm gonna wake up from my dream.
Fuck this.
I had like five ghosts spawned in front of me!
That was actually bullshit.
That's so fucking bullshit.
I'm so mad.
Um, I'm resetting.
I'm resetting the run.
I'm so mad.
I'm just so mad.
I literally had, like, a three-go spot in front of me.
Or three to five.
Do I actually use stun defender charm?
Okay, what's the closest bench?
Oh, it's so far.
I can't.
It's too far.
I'm committed.
Nero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's way too far.
I'm going to commit with the one with the charm I have.
I think I can do it with what I have.
I just got like so unlucky RNG the entire time.
Like literally it was just so unlucky.
With like the spawn.
Oh my god really?
like oh my god like how why
like fuck off really okay i'm getting rage baited i'm actually getting rage baited right now i need to like focus up like i'm playing very sloppy i'm playing very sloppy now that five when five ghosts spawn in front of me it was so tilting it tilted me so hard
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna focus up again.
Because that was such a good run.
It was such a good run, and then I kept getting ghost spawning.
I need to be more patient right now.
I'm not being patient anymore.
Okay.
Oh, what?
What the fuck was that range?
Okay.
Oh, God.
There's too many things to keep track of.
So, I've fucked me over.
Are you serious?
What?
I got the stagger!
I didn't need stagger.
Oh.
I accidentally doubled him.
How?
I got the stagger.
I was trying to...
Oh, my spell double hit him.
That's so unlucky.
I was so confused.
I was like, oh, whoa.
Save.
Whoops.
That was actually an accident.
Are you serious?
Okay.
I might have to restart this run.
Yeah, I'm restarting this run.
Actually, no, I'll play out.
Okay, I'll play out.
Just play out.
Okay.
God, I hate the ghost so much.
The ghost is just so annoying.
Oh, I had to play.
I'm not very consistent with this.
I'm not very consistent with the ground pound, so I don't like doing it.
I don't like doing that move.
I'm not very good with it, too.
Whoops.
Goodbye.
I wake up.
I'm not consistent with the magic pound.
There you go.
It gets so hard for me to do it.
That's why I don't do it.
I already do the fire buff.
Are you serious?
It's...
Yeah, that's good.
I had a really good ghost spawn there.
That's really good for me.
How did he jump so far?
Oh my god.
Yeah.
That's the best I could.
I couldn't heal at once, unfortunately.
Are you serious?
You land on me!
So unlucky!
That was so unlucky.
Of course he spawns in.
Of course the ghost spawns in.
The stupid fucking ghost!
The stupid...
He always spawns in.
Like, oh my god.
He always spawns in when I don't want him to spawn in.
I will beat him.
If it's the last thing I do.
Okay.
Guys, that was bullshit, right?
That was...
That was absolutely bullshit.
What we just saw.
Oh my god.
A fucking course.
A fucking curse.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I need to take it slow.
I'm doing...
I'm being more...
I'm being too impatient now.
I'm actually being, like, super impatient.
Are you serious?
Sometimes, like...
He does the dash, like...
Like, when I'm not expecting it...
I'm so scared of these guys.
I'm actually so scared of them.
I dashed into it accidentally.
Fucking me.
Good.
Oh my god!
I couldn't do anything.
I actually couldn't do anything about it.
Oh, I don't have it.
I have to just hit it.
Are you?
I need a feet.
I need an angry feet.
I'll be right back.
No, I got this.
Got this.
I will kill him.
I will kill.
I got so close.
I will kill him.
I'm locking in.
I'm actually, like, super locked in.
I win these.
Alan, smug.
Alan, take it to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, what?
Okay, I don't know how I got hit there.
Okay, we reset.
We reset.
Wait, oh, fuck it.
I'll tank it.
We reset.
Sorry.
I post-bathroom.
Post-bathroom run.
Okay.
Okay, I will kill him.
I will kill him.
How long have I been on this boss now?
Now!
Now I lock in.
How long have I been?
If I could kill him, every other boss would be so fucking easy.
40 minutes?
Okay.
To be fair, like, I've been first trying every boss.
So like...
What?
Oh my god, I'm getting hit by things I usually never get hit by.
I'm like, how the fuck did I get hit by that?
Oh my god, I got double stunned.
Really, of course I did.
Of course I did, because fuck me, I guess.
Okay, I don't know how the fuck to dodge that.
Of course.
A fucking course!
Oh my god, the ghost!
The ghost.
Okay.
All right.
I'm locking in.
I won't talk much now.
Why do you spawn in front of me?
Why?
When I'm healing!
Okay, sorry.
That actually tilted me so much.
Like, he spawned literally the moment I was healing.
Like him!
That's him!
him like that's so tilting i'm sorry that's actually that's so tilting it's actually so bullshit
okay nice oh
my god that doesn't interrupt his moves too so like that's the worst part It doesn't interrupt.
Oh, my God, of course.
The double hit.
Fucking, of course.
Did I do it?
Wait, did I do it?
I
just!
Oh, let me
hear it out!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I...
Bro, okay.
I think I'm a gamer.
I think I'm a fucking gamer.
You guys want to know why?
Because...
Because when I was in the bathroom...
Because when I went, before I went to the bathroom, before I went to the bathroom, I got a message from my friend, and they were like, you should stop fighting this boss, because it took me three hours, and it's not worth it.
Fuck you!
I did it!
Under an hour!
I'm better than you at this game!
Fuck you!
That's accurate!
Within under an hour you took three hours.
That's fucking right Just better.
I'm just fucking better What do I want to say just go to hell?
I don't care what you want to say I ate right I literally got discriminated be like it's not worth it took me three hours to kill this bot.
Fuck you.
I literally did it under an hour fuck you I'm just better recycle a bit thank you for the super chat thank you thank you next see thank you for the super chat thank you that angry me makes everything better that message made me locked in only spite will fuel me I'm one HP.
It happened in a dream.
How am I one HP?
Who hurt me?
There was someone fucking beating up my body while I was trapped in a goddamn dream?
Like, I'm so full of spite.
Like, who the fuck hurt me?
I'm so confused.
oh my god i'm literally one hp i'm so scared it was a very painful dream your nail isn't yeah it wasn't even fully upgraded nail i literally fought this as i was going along wait that's fucking right only spike can make me fucking stronger where the fuck do i go how upgraded Somebody she is power tripping.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know what this nail is I got two nail upgrades.
Oh, yeah, no, it's a plus plus two plus two nail wait, where am I supposed to go?
Do I just go back?
Oh, I go home.
Okay, bye dead dead body bye Okay, I can actually heal It's like you die in the dream, you die in real life shit.
Like how do I have one HP?
Oh now I can jump here.
Nice.
Alright, what's the closest boss?
Stupid fucking ghost, I hate you.
Okay, wait.
Save, don't you save?
I don't, I just need to find a chair.
Oh wait, hey, there's money.
Oh, do I pogo off the spikes?
God, that sounds like a terrible idea just because I'm bad at pogoing.
Where is this?
Oh!
Okay, wait.
Oh, God.
This is not okay.
I don't like that.
the fuck did i get up there that was unfortunate oh my god i'm just better i'm actually just better like i'm actually i'm just so good at this game
first time playing holiday I can it's not worth it I took me three hours it's not worth it dokey and wait what how many hours it took you again oh there's the bench I'll never forget the power of spite is the only thing that can that can save me
No, what do you mean?
Yeah, what do you mean hours?
What?
Hours.
Okay.
You go back all the way to the left.
To the left, hardest boss.
Not too far.
Wait, hardest boss.
Okay, I said a boss.
No, it's okay.
I already fought the fucking goo boy.
I do not need.
to i do not need to do it again it's fine i just need a boss uh jay thank you for the super chat thank you thank you should go to holly cliffs and find a certain line and do something cool captain thank you with super chat thank you thank you this corpse in white armor all right dream time
it's still a course what dream okay he doesn't want to dream Dream, dream, dream, dream, dream.
Oh,
is my dream now too weak?
Oh, it's okay.
I can upgrade it.
Yeah, I can upgrade my dream now.
Rhea.
Hello.
Hey, another savage house that you discovered someone quite astonishing, little one.
No matter how old I grew, the world still keeps surprises like this shoved away.
all right let us go back up real quick oh wait i need to buy oh i need to buy his charm slots okay uh sorry i need to go somewhere else um i need to go to where was it the was it the resting grounds
okay i think it was the resting grounds for the no i wanted to upgrade my dream Yeah, I'm going to upgrade because I have 400 Essence.
What am I going to do at Crossroads?
Oh, you there, you've returned.
Let me have a look at the dream now.
Your dream now holds over 200 Essence.
You're proving your talents in this collection.
I've seen a great door just outside.
My tribe closed so long ago and forbade its opening.
Oh, but with Farquhanda, I'm the only one.
remember my tribe's still breathing that means i don't even feel bad about breaking a taboo as proof of my belief in you i'll open the door yay
there the door is open you can enter the glade beyond it listen closely in there and you may hear the utterance of bugs long ago all right i see the dreams of this old kingdom are starting to cling to you they're encouraging you started to my dairy work here more exciting being the caretaker of this place hasn't been very stimulating i shouldn't complain though tending these graves and guiding the wielder all penitents for old crimes certain things have to be kept in balance take this trinket for your efforts and return with 500 essence oh nice again 500 essence you're a master in the making well done well done i have a pluck from one of the most precious memories this charm will bring you in the dream though closer together still the secrets of this kingdom won't be able to hide from you any longer taken in return once you have collected 700 essence more gifts reward you all right nice we got it okay let us upgrade our nail and then buy the stupid fucking charm shit where's the
closest one Wait, where is it?
I don't even remember, guys.
Okay, it's...
Down...
Okay.
Yeah, it's down.
Okay, I should buy the charm thing first.
Oh, I need two, peddler.
Okay, I'll just go...
I'll just upgrade my...
I'll just upgrade my charm slots.
I have enough money, right?
It's $800, right?
Is it?
I don't remember.
I'm so fucked up right now.
That goo boy fucked me up, man.
No, I meant my charms.
slots no isn't it no I'm in my slots isn't it here
it's in here I
just don't remember yeah cross the lake oh I should have done the fucking dash thing I'm so fucked up right now I'm not thinking anymore I my mind is my mind is goo after the ghost shit i swear to god i think i could have beaten i could have beaten that other boss um so much faster if the goo ghost didn't fucking spawn the goo ghosts were literally like spawning in front of me okay like it was actually so bullshit
yeah i'm becoming goo man okay how much Okay, shaman stone, gather and swarm.
Do I need more damage?
Okay, okay, I rather...
Oh, I can't get that.
Never mind, do I have anything that's one slot?
Oh my god, that's like triple the damage, right?
It's like, ha ha ha.
Torrance of Aguil, what's this?
Oh, I can charge it faster.
I don't think that really matters.
Fuck it.
It's time.
It's time for my aura.
It's time for the aura.
Alright.
Okay.
What's the closest boss?
Guys.
I'll do one more boss and then I'll call it.
Alright.
What is it?
Which is the closest one?
Which one is the closest one I can get to?
One boss left.
the crossroads?
Okay, I'll go there.
Oh, get out of here.
I don't even remember.
In the wall in crossroads.
First boss.
Oh, the dream boss of the...
Do I have to kill the false knights, though?
Is it worth killing those?
Like, what do I get out of that?
What do I get out of killing the...
Um...
versions of them.
A lot of essence.
Is it worth it, though?
What is it worth it?
Oh yeah, it's infected.
Wait, you're right.
No, not the...
Oh my god, you're right.
It's infected by the ghoul monsters.
God fucking damn it.
I can never escape them.
Okay, but like, how important is the real ending.
How important is the real ending for this game?
Oh my god, these guys are annoying.
It's not.
Alright.
That's why I liked it here.
Alright, what's the next cannon?
What's the next non...
What's the next...
What's the word called?
Main story boss.
That's closest to me.
What's the...
Guys, what's the next main story?
I'll do the dream boss another time.
I want to do a story boss.
I'll do...
Guys, I promise I'll do the...
I promise I'll do him on the next playthrough.
I'm part three.
I just want to do a main story boss.
I'm tired.
I'm too fucked up right now.
I just want to...
Where is that area?
Okay.
It's here.
I'm too fucked up right now.
I went through the goo monster.
I just...
I just want to do a story, boss.
Where is it?
City of tears?
I guess that's the story.
story there's an alien mask okay and that's the story boss right okay where is it this one right here I don't have enough for it okay but like is it this This guy?
Top right.
Up into the right?
Where the fuck is that?
Alright.
What
the fuck?
Where the fuck is this?
Oh!
This thing?
What the fuck is that?
How the fuck do I get to that?
How the fuck do I get to that giant white thing on my map?
Okay, I'll sit down.
How do I get there?
Do I go... Is it the purple?
Do I go here?
Oh!
Oh, I have to go here.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, let's do that.
I deserve to have an ego after that fucking boss fight.
That's all I'm saying.
Anyone that was like, wow, Doki, you're so...
I deserve to have an ego after fucking killing that guy.
I...
You too.
Alright.
This way.
That bus boss...
No, 100 people.
person that took up all my energy.
Holy fuck.
Alright, let's go into that.
Let's go kill the rich.
Eat the rich time.
This time.
Alright.
Brava!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Get down from here!
Stupid bugs.
Just because you think... Just because you fly you think you're better than me?
That's fucking right.
Okay, I can't open that door yet.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
All right.
And then we'll grab the money.
Oh, no.
Oh, it was a trap.
It was a trap.
Get me out of here.
Oh, fuck.
I can't.
Oh my god!
Oh no, I got baited.
Oh my god.
I actually got baited.
I'm fucked.
Okay.
It was a trap all along.
Oh my god.
No!
I got trapped in there.
I can't do it.
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get out of there?
dies the regular mom so gonna die to this guy too we okay yeah now go oh look I'm so I went through a lot today I went through a lot today okay okay let me grab let me take the marker off now marker off is like annoying okay get down here get down from here oh my god i don't even think i have to kill him to get my stuff back that's the worst part Are you serious?
Okay.
I actually have to kill that guy to even get my stuff back.
Bench is right there?
Wait, where's the bench?
Wait, what?
Where's the bench?
Oh, it's above me.
Okay.
Where?
Here?
Oh.
Oh, there's a bench.
bench time all right all right okay I gotta kill all these guys first and then grab my fucking money back stupid come on come back here come back down come up you're such a bitch
you're such a bitch you could have came back
oh my god That was an accident.
Oh my god, I hate these guys so much.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay.
This is so annoying.
Okay, nice.
Holy shit these big bugs are so they like don't even get me anything and they respond they respond this guy respond.
Okay, of course he does of course he responds
Oh, it's because I I rested on the bench.
That's why I Forgot I sat on the bench
Forgot that's that sat on the bench I forgot I
Where do I go?
Wait, where do I go?
Oh, it's to the right.
It's to the right?
Oh.
Wait, what?
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, I did.
It's here.
Oh!
I had to kill that guy to access this place.
Okay, that makes sense.
Because I was so confused.
I was like, what?
Where do I go then?
all right nice okay now unlock that am i closer i'm not even how how far am i
that does not look like i'm closer
jesus christ my god my far callouts are barely do anything
Oh, shit, okay.
That's unlucky.
There we go.
Alright, kill the rich.
Eat the rich.
Sorry, eat the rich.
Because if I say kill the rich, then I might legally be in trouble.
But if I say eat the rich, they'll be like, oh, she's joking, right?
And I'm like, yeah, sure.
Yes.
Alright.
Oh, I already have.
I assume I have to go up.
I'm gonna check over here if there's anything.
Oh, no, I don't.
Okay, I just fell down.
Wait.
I could have just went this way.
It'd be faster.
Okay.
I'll go left or right.
I'll go right first.
I should actually go left first.
Okay, I guess I'll go right.
For us for what we must do.
Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, maybe?
Oh, okay.
I couldn't tell if there's anything over there.
Is these guys again?
Oh my god, it's a goddamn trap again!
Because of course it is.
okay oh my god are you serious
oh i hate these rooms i hate these rooms so much it's all and i went it's okay i just i got my got my government paycheck again it's a trap it's always a trap Okay, then I'm supposed to go left.
Up I'll go.
What's that?
Oh, is this a boss fight?
Alright.
I'm not fully healed.
And I don't know where the bench was.
Okay.
Alright.
What does this boss look like?
The watch, isn't it?
Okay, I don't like that.
Okay.
All right, at least I can heal.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, there's more than one.
All right.
Now, now I definitely don't like that.
Oh, okay.
I definitely don't like that.
Okay.
Help.
One.
down question mark up and then another spawns in
no heals for me
okay what a fun group activity all right that is also my weakness guys that is one of my weaknesses when the enemy is more than one person because i think okay i'm gonna say it But I find, like, boss fights where they just have multiple enemies to be cheap boss fight designs.
I'm sorry.
I think these types of boss fights where it's more than one boss is very cheap design.
I hate these types of boss fights.
I hate those designs.
I hate it so much.
You look like a cheap boss to sign.
What do you mean I'm Jane Silkson?
I'm just Jane Silkson.
You're just jealous.
Trying to kill it before he fucking...
Okay, there we go.
That's good.
Oh my god.
Now there's two?
How did they get beat because...
This is actually not fair.
Oh my god.
I don't even know how you should be able to dodge that.
I...
Oh my god.
Alright.
Pull.
Yeah, that was not a very...
Oh my god, okay, I'm just gonna, okay, I'm, okay, whatever.
Let me sit on my bench again.
Let me just sit on my bench.
All right, it's this way.
Are you serious?
Like, you chased me all the way here?
Nerd.
Look what he likes you.
You can try hard.
There you go.
Yeah, you like that?
Look what you did.
Look what you made me do.
I wasn't even trying to kill you.
God, I wish I had my Among Us sprite.
Maybe if it was Among Us, I'd choose more.
I'd focus more.
Okay.
Alright, we got one out.
It's just harder.
It's a lot harder, more so of the fact that they both spin.
Like, when they corner me like that, it just sucks.
Like, I don't know.
It's just very unlucky when they corner me like that.
Okay.
especially when they do that jump thing jesus christ that jump thing it's so fucking dumb oh my god like oh my that's not oh my god it's not fair holy i wish i could okay like i need that magic here okay i don't need the compass if i get through this i have two slots if I have anything,
that's good.
I'll just put the, maybe more of the spells.
Oh, okay.
I could do dash, too.
I don't think I need the dash.
Okay.
I'll get the, I'll get the soul sting.
I'm just not good at the dash spell.
I feel, I mean, I guess like, it'll be good to learn it for the sake that, okay.
Alright, get out of here.
Okay.
I'm just not good with it.
I only know how to do fireball.
Fireball!
And drop a chandelier.
Wait, how do I drop the chandelier?
Give me the fucking elevator.
How do I drop the chandelier, though?
Wait.
He hurts me?
I thought we're friends!
Break the wall.
Why do I break the wall?
Oh well.
Well, I guess we'll never learn.
I guess we won't learn how to break the wall.
I gotta
focus for this.
I'm just gonna try my best to focus for it.
Oh, I didn't see.
the jump for it.
Oh, that's scary.
That's scary.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh, no!
I'm one life.
Are you fucking...
Oh!
This boss is so hard.
This boss is actually so hard.
That is so...
The shit that you do is so bullshit.
Yeah.
Oh.
Left the room up top?
How so?
Before I enter the arena.
Oh, this?
What the fuck?
Oh.
Did I do it?
oh my god i killed some of them thank god oh and then my guy decided to kill me okay i killed one of them at least that's one one thing i have to worry less about i'm jumping too much uh i'm not surprised because i'm it's just from like the goo monster made me jump so much you know oh my god that was a mistake there it's just from like just fighting the goo monster made me He jumped so much earlier.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is bad that they're all out.
Okay.
Oh.
I actually have to focus so much for these guys.
Okay, one, two more.
Oh!
It's unlucky.
For me.
Oh, are you serious?
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
Of course, they both decide.
Oh, they both decide to spin at irregular timing.
They both spun irregularly.
Yeah.
Oh.
They like it was such hard.
It was so hard to time that because the they both like spun in such a weird time in there I'm getting closer.
I'm figuring it out Oh, I'm just that I'm worse when it's like multiple characters Because it's like I have to keep track of like so many different things at the same time But if it's one person if I'm fighting one person, it's a lot easier to discern like the ghost was fucking with me The ghost was the thing that was fucking with me,
but when I like but They were at least one hit.
But, like, for this, they're, like, multiple hits, and it's, like, there's, like, so many of them to, like, keep track of.
So, like, that's what messes with me the most.
I just get messed up when, like, there's so many people I have to fight.
Like, right now, see, like, like, like...
I'm also, like, messing up really badly.
I shouldn't be messing up this run this guy because he's like one person There you go I can heal too if you just get out of time to heal I'm trying to like like
what the fuck was that like actually what was that
yeah okay my timing for these guys are so hard i was i'm messing up the timing for them
no oh my god i did it i did it oh my god oh my god i did it oh i think This one's not as annoying as cool boy, but I hate multiple enemies.
I hate them so much I just find I just find it.
I just find it so annoying and to me it feels so cheap Because it's much more RNG when there's like multiple enemies
Oh my god, we did it though.
Holy shit All right, that's a story boss, right?
Kira, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Like, where am I?
Oh, there's a lot of dead bugs here.
Alright, good.
I'm glad this is a required boss.
Where am I?
Oh, wait, what?
What's over here?
Nothing?
Oh, no.
It's fine.
Just do this.
Maybe there'll be something over there.
I don't need the elevator.
I'll do this myself.
Hello?
I'll make my own elevator.
Yeah, I took that bait.
It baited me.
There were so many secret rooms, and then suddenly zero secret rooms.
Hello?
A sleeping figure lays on top.
Oh, master.
So young.
All right.
I got a heal.
Imagine if that guy killed me.
I did not realize how low my HP was.
I...
Oh, my God.
I'm dreaming.
Okay.
Hello.
What's this?
Working beloved.
Am I supposed to kill him?
Asleep to serve.
The bonds must remain.
Remain.
Is he done?
All right.
Remain.
I think he's done, guys.
You guys, guys, what do you think he's going to stay next?
Remain.
Okay.
Now it's murder time.
There we go.
Remain.
I'll be the focus.
I'm focusing.
First try.
Huh?
Easiest boss of my life.
Hitless run, guys.
Look at that.
No hits.
Okay.
No hits, too.
I killed...
Oh, I'm such a gamer.
I killed him with zero hits.
I guess I go down now.
Alright, we got a fine bench and then we'll call it here.
Oh my gosh, I've been too savage.
I did say today was going to be long stream.
I was going to pay.
I made so much progress.
Am I finishing this faster than people expected?
I feel like I am.
Okay, where do I go?
go way faster i told you guys we're gonna finish on that before sex song i told you nobody believe me yeah all right how do i get down i'd be a few oh yeah i'd be a three hour boss how long okay how long did that boss take you guys there was one guy one dragon that was like i'm gonna try and fight this boss at the same time as you and then see if i could beat it before you did you did you oh the goo boy was optional well the goo boy was not optional it was just to show everyone how much of a gamer i am i have to remind everybody that i am in fact yes a gamer
probably still fighting it Can I just go back to the bench?
I assume so, right?
I just did that to flex.
And my nail was apparently underleveled, too, for it.
It was to send...
Exactly.
The good boy was to send a fucking message.
Alright, we're gonna call it here, guys.
That was fun.
I've been having a really fun time.
playing Hollow Knight so far and honestly I've been enjoying the ride it makes me you know I've never played in Metrovania before but Hollow Knight has actually been incredibly fun I definitely like the boss fights a lot I think the boss fights are very rewarding I'm always very lost the only thing that I will criticize is that I'm always very lost but that's just me I've always been lost in multiple games.
This is not a...
And this is no exception.
But I think I've been doing pretty well.
I've been picking up stuff really well.
And even though I'm really bad platformers, I think I'm doing pretty alright.
Zonderman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The game does kind of mechanic where you can upgrade or no bosses get a little bit more HP.
Oh, I didn't know.
That's interesting.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, guys.
I am blowing the head off now.
Instead of some work to do after stream, but after that, I'm going to grab food, do a little bit of work, and then sleep.
And tomorrow is Minecraft!
It's the Doki SMP.
If you are a member, I am streaming on the member's Minecraft server, but as a public stream.
So any member can fully join the server.
The instructions are in the community post if you are a member, Goon.
I'll also link it in the waiting room for tomorrow's stream.
Those who want to get access to it.
Hey, guys!
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, Check out him around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.